all you can
[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to another
episode of the dope as usual podcast i'm
your host
dopaziola thomas whatever you want to
call me thank you guys for joining us
for another episode i think this is
episode 10.
we're officially 10 episodes in guys
thank you so [ __ ] much we just hit
60k on our youtube for this channel it's
it's picking up
thank you guys so much for supporting
the apple podcast um
spotify everything all the platforms
appreciate you guys and another big cool
piece of news
our clips channel just got monetized i
never thought we'd get monetized on any
type of [ __ ] anything
thank you guys so much for supporting
for following we hit 10k on that
it's just it's cool to see it actually
work
when me and marty vs started this like i
really hope it goes how we want and it's
actually starting to work so thank you
guys for the support
um uh let's get right into this guys
today
obviously is a solo podcast the last
solo one we did was three hours long
i only planned on it to be an hour i
just kept [ __ ] ranting i don't even
remember what we talked about until we
watched the [ __ ]
that's that's what happens in these
podcasts so if you're at home if you're
a new fan especially
sorry and get used to the ranting
because it's not going away unless
no there's nothing there's nothing's
going to stop that thank you guys so
much for hanging out marty how you doing
i'm feeling amazing we just did a nice
vlog video we're doing the podcast we
dawned on us that we hadn't even put out
a podcast video on the dopaziola channel
so
yes so we filmed a vlog today guys and a
little piece of information
marty murdered something today
i've been a vegetarian since i was like
he's 20.
first he killed it it wasn't his fault
so marty was flying the drone and i was
like yo it looks kind of dangerous
aren't those blades scary goes uh
i think you're okay so we're doing this
shot guys real quick before we even get
into the podcast we're doing this shot
and mario just gracefully you know
scene first of all we're in like
paradise basically yeah
we're the top of the highest point of
beverly hills there's trippy labyrinth
style statues everywhere
scary statues everywhere we're at the
super super ball and ass house because
of the ad agency we signed to notorious
they have a house just for content and
it's
it's like a 60 million dollar house i'm
gonna say 60 plus
but their backyard is a park kind of
like uh
what was it richie rich with macaulay
kogan yes it's like that's not a park
that's my backyard
so that's pretty much what happened and
as marty is
driving and flying this drone off so
we're gonna get a shot
remember it's like a paradise there's
pretty ass butterflies and like birds
flying around
it's like some snow white [ __ ] and marty
just goes
up with the drone and shred cuts this
nice ass
huge butterfly in half
that's the top of this house holy
it's so it's such a nice butterfly marty
went up with the drone and it
[ __ ] randy johnson johnson a
videographer
it cut him in half no no
in half and i couldn't kill it it was
still flopping around so i had to make
marty kill it
i felt too bad no you felt all amazing
you're like kill it
no i wanted you to kill it because it
was flopping like that [ __ ] hurt
his wings are in half so marty murdered
the fate of the earth that's what that
was
it was such a nice looking butterfly and
it was just split in half
i'm probably going to get an invoice for
that from the property oh could you
imagine
could those are big ass butterflies
though but yes that's what we did guys
uh the dopagiola channel we haven't even
really talked about the podcast
and that's my biggest platform it just
goes to show we're
dedicated to working on this [ __ ] and i
forgot like yo you have a really big
outlet
use it i forgot i just straight up
forgot because we've been so busy so
yes we did a vlog today showing you what
goes into the podcast day
so some of this right now that you're
watching might be in the episode of
dopaziola
so guys i just want to start off by
saying yes marty's murderer
and uh he texted me yesterday he just
went yeah you have a murderer
he texts me yesterday says i feel like
killing something so i don't think it
was on accident
no [ __ ] butterflies look at me wrong
while we're filming because i don't know
what i'll do
marty's a monster no it was sad i was
sad
that was a nice ass butterfly so we
started off this podcast talking about
death
um and butterflies which is [ __ ]
ridiculous let me light one of these
[ __ ] joints um before we even
get
into this i want like i don't really get
into this kind of stuff i don't talk
about the news too often
but i haven't seen so much of this and i
am shocked
i i didn't know this kind of [ __ ] still
goes on and it's just
starting i know you can see the notes
marty i know you see what's coming up
next
yo there's a there's asian hate crimes
going on dude
did you know this marty i mean i live in
one of the biggest asian places in
america
yeah but if you punch an asian guy down
there you get swarmed by everybody
they're punching fools and random well
first go first we have a lot of asian
people too but
yo what is going on when the [ __ ] did
that
start man it's got to be covid related
it's like
it has to be it has to be dude because
it makes no sense like you're
do you know what i saw today that like
just
maybe that's why i was pissed off this
morning i saw a video of some dude
i think it was in frisco walks by and
just pops this
old asian woman pops her on the ground
starts beating the [ __ ] out of her
two big ass dudes standing in the
building that the cameras are in
they just go and close the door bro they
didn't even try to help this woman she's
just laid out
he went closed the door i couldn't
believe it marty
i'll show you the video it's it's really
really [ __ ] sad
yeah it's really [ __ ] sad dude you
could tell that
she just got her ass whooped not even
just get her ass guy or girl anybody
just closed the door
didn't even try to like are you okay
nothing
it was very very [ __ ] up and that's
not even the worst
what was it and it was atlanta right guy
walked into the [ __ ] asian
salon and blew hella people away
apparently
[ __ ] i don't the [ __ ] i don't want on
man
i mean what was really [ __ ] up is that
i thought to myself i'm like well at
least with kova there's no more mass
shootings going on like at least all the
nationals it's back to
a break it's bad but uh apparently
that's not the case anymore
i don't know i mean you're gonna get any
time that something happens
the most ignorant of us are gonna
generalize and categorize and all that
but
it's just weird it's like after [ __ ]
world war ii and they came back all your
japanese put you in
you know that japanese internment camp
is in merced california
marty that's where i smoke weed at
during the carnival
you guys got all like jessie may said
just the top highlights of everything
our whole uh swap meet on saturdays all
the horse stables and everything used to
be the internment camp
so we uh oh back to that i was in this
ninth grade and i'm polite i'm real
polite so even if i don't give a [ __ ] if
no one else is listening i'll pretend to
listen
because i don't want you to feel stupid
two uh
prison ex-prisoners in the pow camp from
uh japanese people
and it came to our class merced and told
everybody
everybody was so [ __ ] rude i just had
to like
try my best to sit there and listen
because you could tell these old
japanese people were like
they don't give a [ __ ] i could see it on
their face that they looked at us like
yep see that's it right there mercedes
detention facility the japanese in the
40s dude isn't that
crazy as [ __ ] look it in jail in modern
america
[ __ ] out of here that's crazy
but yeah that happened merced that's
merced isn't that crazy
we had when 9 11 happened they came and
did like an fbi raid of some of the
yemenis people in my town
really yeah it was a pretty like one of
my best friend's cousins went down over
it
were they dudes at the bed they were
tied to al qaeda oh [ __ ] i thought she
meant they were just doing it because
they're colored
no like they allegedly i have no idea i
know that i mean we never i never heard
about any of these fools again but they
were allegedly going back and forth to
some training camps or whatever but
that's a lot different than this that's
sad the whole america just said yo
yo we're not and they didn't give them
their property back can you imagine that
right now
say you're whatever color you are and
the government says no we went to war
with you guys
guys to put you in jail until we figure
out who's a spy
also all the businesses you have gone
all the land
hours and then after everybody was like
no no you're good
turns out you weren't a spy but we're
gonna keep your [ __ ]
that's what happened it's the american
way it's america they just stalled
they stole texas they stole the whole
thing they stole the whole [ __ ] state
man
they stole that whole state so
[ __ ] over there get out of my
country
that's not even your [ __ ] country
let's just start off with that
um so yeah there's asian hate crimes
going on man i can't
i've been seeing people and stop asian
hey [ __ ] stand up don't be just
tagging [ __ ]
i hate [ __ ] do that [ __ ] get up
go stop it if you see somebody being a
dick stop it
i see i i never got those vibes towards
asian people i've
never even knew at all since when
do the quietest ethnicity group in
america
the ones that keep to themselves the
most you start getting punched in the
face you ever been to irvine
yo my homie lives in garden grove and
it's the biggest
like biggest uh population of vietnamese
people
out of vietnam yeah and it is [ __ ]
crazy to see a whole town i'm the only
one that's brown
or [ __ ] like that it's it's very like
oh [ __ ] there's i'm not cultured i am
ignorant when my daughter went to
elementary school in irvine she was like
the minority you know because she's
white
because there's so many asian kids there
which was fine with me i was totally
yeah it's just a whole different
feeling huh okay well no one's
belittling me so why the [ __ ] are we
doing it to them i remember in merced
they i think it was laotian people 200
000 uh refugees got dropped off in
merced county
and that's the year i had hella asian
homies i think i've told you these
stories they actually saved my life when
i was about 19
being friends with those guys as
elementary kids i almost got
i thought i was gonna get murdered by
these asian crips
you're blowing my mind with this asian
asian gangster marty doesn't really have
there's not really asian people in
buffalo and when i told marty there's
asian gangs he goes what do you
mean gangs i go you don't have
asian gang bangers in [ __ ] new york
what do you mean gangs i told marty
the scariest people for me gang banger
wise are asian dudes
me growing up like no no you don't fight
the asian gangbangers that are bald
headed with just bangs and they flip
them back that means i got a oozy i
don't
[ __ ] with that's the only asian gang man
you ever seen right here rush hour
gentile
gentile he was scary man yeah
he was scary no um i used to play a
street fighter at the boys and girls
club there was this tall asian [ __ ] kid
and he had no uh no hair but the front
bangs and he would comb him back
and i remember i was losing i was trying
to beat guile
and he's like let me try your next round
and he beat him for me and i took over
you know what i mean like it was cool it
was and he got [ __ ] murked i remember
he got killed
and um my friend lou i hung out with
this kid lou
i don't know dude i don't see how you
could just hate on somebody because
they're what the [ __ ] is happening
yo you start a coronavirus you're in
america [ __ ] that [ __ ] didn't
start here or
did it i don't [ __ ] know but people
taking it out on asian people because
there was a virus is
unfucking believable that is insane
i just don't get it i mean [ __ ] it fits
right in line with everything else that
goes on so like
i don't i just don't get it dude i don't
get it i um i used to fish for crawdads
and i was with this guy kyle and lou and
i remember his brother had just died
his brother just got killed but he was
like an active gang banger
we were walking by the bridge over
highly park and he starts telling us a
story because i never asked like how'd
your brother die
and as we're fishing for crawdads we
were standing five feet before his
brother got killed
he started telling us like he has the
bridge and go your brother got killed
he's like yeah he got hella stabbed
and then they threw him over it's like a
10-foot drop but when they threw him
over he was already bleeding out he just
died in
[ __ ] creek what the [ __ ] man
that's crazy bro just got stabbed up and
killed like 18 years old
when i was like probably seven eight
years old my best friend was asian he
was adopted from
somewhere i have no [ __ ] idea one
career or something i don't know
you're mad at her keep going i've been
listening for sure i'm not even gonna
attempt to act like i know what
countries are going on over there
so we're best friends elementary school
we stopped seeing each other
i i don't see this kid till i'm probably
like maybe
16 17. we just so happen to be at the
same playground playing basketball
but we don't i don't say anything i act
like i'm not me and he's not him and we
don't
act like we knew each other when we were
kids and [ __ ] but we played basketball
i don't [ __ ] know but then like maybe
a year later i'm dating this girl and
she's like
yeah i'm going to my funeral for this
kid in my school killed himself his
name's blah blah blah and it was him
i was like damn he killed himself marty
yeah she just said something to him
well [ __ ] i guess so oh that's
yeah that was [ __ ] up but yeah i was
like probably my only asian friend
growing up i think like there really was
barely any asian people and uh buffalo
whatsoever
that's so sad dude jesus i remember my
grandpa told me
my grandpa told him he passed away i
remember i was like 18 he was telling me
about his
childhood we don't really i guess you
talk you guys have seen other stories he
wouldn't really talk so much but
he was like 11 and he was walking to
school with this [ __ ] kid that got
picked on all the time and he was like i
just made it my friend because you
always got [ __ ] with
he walks right same path as me and my
grandpa was like cool as [ __ ] so
you know he's that cool kid so he was
just trying to be nice
and he said he got picked on all the
[ __ ] time but he would go there hang
out with him and he's like he just
became my friend i just hung out with
him he's a little off
and he said he didn't see him for like
two days he went over there and his mom
was like yeah he killed himself
[ __ ] 11 years old damn damn that's
the most terrifying thing on earth
that's scary because people were picking
on his ass
what beating his ass this is the 60s 50s
it's like yo you guys don't realize like
picking on people [ __ ] are not
strong like you
if they were strong they would beat your
[ __ ] ass for picking on them
so obviously they're not mentally s
they're not mentally like
yeah that's why i [ __ ] spazzed out on
my kids [ __ ] school because
they're letting all this [ __ ] slide and
it's like kids kill themselves over this
[ __ ] you guys need
goddamn snap into action marty had to
check a 12 year old boy
he's been checking kids parents teachers
everybody's got to check it we won't go
too into it before
you tell me the story marty had to check
a 12 year old boy and this boy
is uh openly gay so marty's like i don't
want it to be a hate crime
like marty nobody cares that he's gay
nobody's going to say anything
you're checking him because he's talking
[ __ ] to your daughter
you're gay or not you better get ready
to get punched little kid
like i'll pay a nine-year-old to whoop
your ass that's the thing you can't hit
him he's underage a little [ __ ]
because i snap right back into my old
psycho self when some [ __ ] like that
happens like
oh no i've heard so many stories of
barney so you know i just i waited
outside his house you know a couple
nights in the room
wait stop what do you mean i stalked
this guy because i was trying to beat
the [ __ ] out of him when he walked out
of his house
get out of here marty you're a
psychopath
i'm taking all that as soon as this [ __ ]
started to happen i'm like oh
man listen you don't know how many times
i slept in ditches
just to [ __ ] peep somebody going to
work part of your psych
i slept on it for about two nights and
i'm like listen we're gonna call the
principal
marty really really i remember he told
me he really like
should i [ __ ] this kid up like marty you
are in your 30s and a dad
you cannot beat up a 12 year old kid at
no point was i going to beat this 12
year old i know you weren't
really going to be for sure gonna
[ __ ] find him walking to school and
run up on him and [ __ ] and put the fear
of god
and his parents or whoever was with him
[Laughter]
could you imagine get the [ __ ] back up
back to a little boy he was like
that's not even how you do it that's not
even ski mask
man listen everybody's got a mask on you
got to walk up and say some
[ __ ] just [ __ ] that doesn't even
sound psychotic but is so psychotic the
kid goes talking my daughter like that
i'm gonna fold your clothes
real good what did you say that doesn't
make sense
i'm gonna clean the [ __ ] out of your car
wait he's 12 young got a car yeah
no but the thing is like you can see it
on marty's oh wait we have a camera on
you yeah i can see the
anger right here you look mad
pisses me off when you start obviously
saying some crazy [ __ ] to my kid but
then it pisses me off because it's like
also
you're 12 you don't realize what type of
[ __ ] you're getting yourself into this
is what i did tell the kid like
you probably don't even [ __ ] realize
what you're doing right now because
yeah you're getting people all worked up
at you you don't even know what the [ __ ]
they are
yeah you don't know it's like the
crystal [ __ ] you don't know who's
[ __ ] looking at you when you go
outside
it's that's always the thing it's the
craig and day day situation you don't
know whose grandma you just said suck a
dick and all the crips come to shoot
your ass
yeah you got to be careful especially
little boys talking to [ __ ] girls in
her school if anybody's under
anybody at all wait any age always
remember
you got to be care like when i'm in
traffic i gotta refrain go you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i gotta stop doing that because
like all right
all right let's calm down let's not get
upset because i don't want to beat your
husband's ass
too i don't want this to keep going
it's just not good violence is never the
[ __ ] answer unless
it's that's the only option but now you
got some [ __ ] like okay i talked to the
principal about it [ __ ] those principles
they're not doing [ __ ] about it
nobody's doing that that's crazy that's
crazy sorry we are off on this this
topic guys but this is some real [ __ ]
people got kids
people got [ __ ] kids like we're off
on this topic and
they're not doing anything about it so
you had to check this little 12 year old
yeah
i took my kid out of the school all
right we're already risking our old
family by sending her to this goddamn
school
so you got around this wonky abbc
bd schedule whatever you guys feel like
doing every other week like enough
it's over you're not going to do
anything about this she ain't coming no
more
jordan he's like bernie mac going back
and forth to the school and then you
we're going to be doing all this
a b b b c d d that's how i feel like he
would have took that one
no someone a [ __ ] yeah
yeah but it was funny i called all this
i knew as soon as middle school hit all
this [ __ ] was coming i feel like i
manifested it
you probably did manifest it uh whatever
she what i will tell you is
she got the flip phone yeah she got
signed up for three days a week of
basketball and a fourth day week at
volleyball so
she got the flip phone and they told me
this 15 years ago like
wait that's a punishment [ __ ] i
know like deanna said i didn't get my
own phone until i was in college or my
own computer i'm like
yeah that is how it's supposed to
[ __ ] be we don't owe these kids this
[ __ ]
we don't owe these kids that's how they
act the principal was like yeah like
parents feel like they're entitled to
get their kids phones and [ __ ] just have
access to the full-blown internet
yeah that's what [ __ ] kids up that's
what makes kids think they're tight
right now
like i said it always just takes you to
get knocked out in public
for you to start realizing that the
world is real say some
slick [ __ ] like that to someone's
daughter watch you get knocked the [ __ ]
out
well one of these kids just texted my
daughter this girl and put like 50 kids
on the channel oh yeah that's different
and then april april took the phone and
went in my wife takes my
daughter's phone starts going in on this
girl if you want to talk [ __ ] bring your
mom to my house all this [ __ ] she called
her mom all this [ __ ]
like uh april got nothing
you've got nothing but problems all this
[ __ ] if you want to fight somebody come
[ __ ] fight me
all this [ __ ] on the text of this 12
year old girl then all it was like a
dopaziola chat
oh hold on not even that guys explain it
live chat
they were in an open like instagram chat
so they are
saying a group chat so when everyone
tried to call my daughter i'm gonna beat
her after
the [ __ ] out of you for nothing out of
[ __ ] nowhere
just like thirsty [ __ ] and uh yeah then
april got
that then all the kids start coming at
this girl here's the funniest part all
the kids yeah that's a [ __ ] you know
you're embarrassing all this stuff
they're all you know
all these comments backfiring at this
girl the girl's mom walks in guys all
right
listen the girl tells her mom shows her
mom
the phone and she's recording it at the
same time
so the girl shows her mom the phone and
then she's like this
you know so-and-so's mom is yelling at
me on here and she's the girl's mom's
reading it going
well uh yeah you are threatening her
here you can't say that she's probably
gonna go to the principal
uh yeah well you know she is being
pretty ghetto about this
but you really can't talk like that to
kids that's how the mom
reacts reacts to her kid threatening the
kid posts that
on the same group chat her mom's
reaction
why would you post the [ __ ] that makes
you look worse she's a [ __ ] dumbass i
have no idea
she looks super poster mom's reaction
their mom doesn't know
so now me and april are sitting there
listening to the mom's reaction going
what the [ __ ]
because we called the mom she didn't
call back isn't that insane so now while
all this happened now the mom calls back
and she gets on the phone and she's
trying to [ __ ]
like tough and we're like trying to
speak to her sensibly like
no it's not okay for kids to violently
threaten other kids i don't care if your
kid's gotten picked on before it's got
nothing to do with this yeah because
she's calling my kids say it again
though
the mom says well my daughter's been
bullied
like it's an excuse to bully yeah she
and the kid was violently threatening my
daughter like your daughter's nice
nicest kid on the planet it was very
nice yeah super quiet so
you know it literally was out of nowhere
so then then we
then we're like you realize she just
posted your reaction to disciplining her
like you didn't [ __ ] discipline her
i'm like i took the phone like
i started talking to her like her dad
and [ __ ] yeah like
what is this no it's the mom scolding
them off yeah like i've told this [ __ ]
[ __ ] get it together i'm not asking
you i'm telling you you told her there's
no more
talking to my kid get the [ __ ] together
could you imagine yeah it feels
and i'm so much older than these moms
could you imagine some kid 20 years
younger than you telling you to get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] together
you are not that old marty no for my
daughter's
age i know but you're saying 20 years
older than the moms younger younger
yeah they're not they're older they're
where they would be [ __ ] like 14.
no no no no listen you got to understand
ariana's 13
i'm 34. so like yeah yeah these
yeah you're not old no they're hurt
those parents are older than us first
oh you said the parents are older oh i
thought you said they were way
20 years younger parents are older oh
okay so
marty told me this the other day guys
and what i got from marty was just
nothing but like hilarious things
because marty's wife april is very very
like nice looks
she's a realtor you know she might [ __ ]
you up
there's a small side that like oh she
might be here
she used to be people's asses back in
the day yeah you told me that i didn't
put it out there but damn
so barely marty's wife used to [ __ ]
people up
did she push a man in the [ __ ] mouth
she punched plenty of dudes in the face
there was i heard when i got with her i
started hearing all these crazy stories
every time i met one of her other
friends i'd hear about somebody's asking
yeah she broke this guy's leg
no the one time you're talking about was
we had this
we had this stupid-ass situation with
these two dudes we worked with
where like she had just sold my one
friend his first house they're all over
there hanging out
and the kids want to go like get some
food or something these kids are older
than us at the time even like 28 29
i'm like 22. yeah so we just got the 300
c
which was like the nice you're in
buffalo yeah yeah we got the 300 c
april came from work she goes over my
boy sean's house she's friends with his
fiancee or whatever they're hanging out
with their friends from work she'd been
known these kids forever
uh she like lets them take the 300 to go
to the gas station or something but they
end up going in her
apron she worked at olive garden they
went in their apron and like [ __ ] with
their tip money
okay they didn't steal the money but
they [ __ ] with it meaning that what is
that yeah what is that if there was 420s
in there
now there's 320s and 210s or something
oh they wouldn't trade it out and got
changed
without asking yeah without asking and
it was like some [ __ ] like they didn't
ask to take the car or some [ __ ] too so
they stole your [ __ ] car
they did some [ __ ] like that where it
was like lights
they came back and now they're trying to
play around with like the money
but they didn't steal it but they're
lying to april so immediately
i shoot right over there now mind you
it's my best friend's house you just my
april just sold him
best friend's house and he's the one
doing it no no it's just his house he's
who's the ones doing it
our two friends from work oh you guys
are all just happen to be hanging out
you got you we're at the house
so yeah anyway we this one of the kids
comes out and he starts
we're in the driveway now i got the
screw in my hand
for those of you that haven't watched
the first couple episodes marty's from
the ghetto and used to carry around a
screw so if he had to fight
he had to screw it out he's trying to
blast this [ __ ] kid and he was older
than me
but he he starts coming out he's yo it
was so creepy he put it on his dead
dad he goes i put it on my dad bro
we i don't know your dad had just passed
away my dad was
dying dying at that time very real bad
he it took it was a
long drawn-out thing and this was at a
chapter in my life where it was
real bad like i was walking around with
a lot of rage at this time just
outside of what these kids were [ __ ]
doing yeah so like
he's putting it on his dead dad he's
doing all this [ __ ] i'm not saying [ __ ]
to him
i see the other kid peeking out of the
door but he's not coming outside
so guilty i'm trying not to get the cops
called i work with these kids i've been
knowing these kids it's not even a big
[ __ ] deal they're just i just can't
let this [ __ ] slide april's mad
so then after about 15 minutes of him
doing all this [ __ ]
wow then literally he just okay sorry
[ __ ] i'm dead
i'm sorry i'm [ __ ] sorry i'm sorry
i'm [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm sorry
did you punch me right in the [ __ ]
face no no no
no i would have no no it would have been
wrong for me then what happened
so no i'm moving along okay so
so he does that and i just look at him
like i'm just [ __ ] disgusted with
this fool
and i told him i was [ __ ] disgusted
with him and i went back ariana was a
year old
i wasn't about to go to jail over this
not even a year like a newborn
so anyway now i gotta go back to work
with these [ __ ] every day
so now they're now i'm just looking past
them every day
and that pisses them off so the one you
know the one time
they're the the kid that wouldn't come
out of the house who had been known in
april since they were little kids
they're down
april's downtown with her friends she
gives the kid a ride home
after this yeah this is so like their
you guys are friends friends if
she let it go yeah yeah so like yeah
they she had known this kid way before
me
all right so it's not like not stolen
money's going to stop a situation so
they're still friends you just pissed
and checked them yeah okay 100
okay can't have that [ __ ] going on so
then she gives this kid a ride home from
downtown
probably about maybe two three four
weeks later and he's mad because like we
were friends but now i'm like
like i said looking past them not even
[ __ ] paying attention he walks past
me i just [ __ ]
like he's not even there on that type of
[ __ ] so he starts talking [ __ ] in the
back seat
man this [ __ ] won't talk to me
that was some [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
he's probably drunk he starts talking
some [ __ ] in the back seat
april's left april's like you're not
gonna be talking [ __ ]
okay regardless of what's going on
you're not gonna be talking [ __ ]
so i'm i'm home i'm asleep it's like
three in the morning two in the morning
whatever
she's got one of her other friends with
her maybe two of her other friends
she pulls over in a mcdonald's parking
lot pulls this [ __ ] out of the
car
throws him into a snowbank and hits him
with a flurry of combinations
leaves him in the snow bank and that was
that
wait her friend that she knew forever
yeah she wasn't friends with him after
that
no they were still he knew i mean [ __ ]
what do you think yo
he was still okay with it yeah man i
excited she busted his ass up if she hit
him a few times
yeah no matter what girl or not yeah you
get popped in the mouth like that yeah
no she's she's a girl that punches dudes
too back in that time so
i just don't like it being on my mind i
hate knowing that something happened
that like
i can't ignore and now you've put what i
really
used to happen in buffalo all the time
people do some [ __ ] that put you in a
position that you know you got to react
it's like i don't want to be in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what i don't go to i
don't go to anywhere i don't go to bars
merced because of that
yeah you're not allowed to wear color
bread or blue or any kind of
sports team in a bar in merced you know
that i believe it
it's because [ __ ] keep where
you from i know we're 32.
yeah i got kids yeah i got a cha i'm
banging on you like bro
give it the [ __ ] up if you are not
getting paid
from this gang why the [ __ ] are you in
this gang
it's like you're working for free and
then again i don't know the inner
workings of a gang
i've never done that [ __ ] it's just to
me it's like yo
just just cause just we're in a hometown
my homie jeebus
is the smallest dude ever he got hit up
at the bar
and asked were you were you from full
because he had
he wears really nice js and there was
red on him
and he got hit he was wearing a star
wars shirt by the way jesus yeah hit up
and that's where he's from because he
had red [ __ ] shoes on
it there's a point where it's like
you got to feel stupid when you ask you
kind of feel stupid
i'm from merced you think i'm being this
bar if i wasn't from merced it's a
little town
it's just it's just everywhere you guys
got to remember for all you fools out
there that do check people and all that
[ __ ]
what if a [ __ ] is colorblind
you all from the ghetto and i'm
colorblind i've been beat up for
everybody
yo that's a good character there's a guy
with always a black guy why do you
always got a black eye
i'm color blind what's that mean i live
in the ghetto and i don't know if i'm
wearing red or blue and people keep
beating my ass
first time everywhere uh blue was in l.a
i remember i remember it was my first
apartment at the met and i was picked up
the shirt
i went wow i'm about to put a blue shirt
on and walk outside
never have i done that before it's my
favorite [ __ ] color um
yo how the [ __ ] did we get on that topic
i don't know
so we'll wrap that part up with marty
had to check a child
uh his wife had to check a different
child
where you from kids my mom's house
yo stop dude one time just real quick i
don't know why the [ __ ] i'm bringing
this up
me and my my dad used to uh obviously
you guys know my dad used to be a
[ __ ] drug addict
but when he wasn't drink on drugs he was
trying to be so where he would drink
my dad drinks like i smoke weed my dad
could drink
i've seen my dad chug this is not any
part of the story i see my dad chugging
an entire fifth of jack daniels
without stopping and he was already
[ __ ] up
he was in the walkway between the
bathroom and the stairs in the
downstairs part
in portland when we lived in that house
i was like you can go upstairs and
downstairs
that one he was down there and i saw him
come out and start it and
crack it and start drinking some
drinking stuff and he drank the whole
[ __ ] bottle guys i've never seen
anybody chug a fifth
it was kind of it was very sad it's
always sad
it was very sad actually it was really
sad and uh
he fell asleep like 25 minutes later but
i remember i've never seen anybody just
get so drunk within like five minutes
and he was [ __ ] up and that's my dad
anyway why the [ __ ] did i bring that up
i couldn't tell you damn
how did we get here again we're gonna
make a shirt that says what the [ __ ]
were we talking about
where the [ __ ] did we get here again i
cannot remember what i was talking about
i brought up my dad for a [ __ ] reason
uh said he can drink a lot
damn it i don't remember guys i really
really and watch when i watch this back
i'm gonna go full come on you were just
talking about it damn it
maybe we'll come back to it [ __ ] i was
talking about my dad
he drinks a lot i think that's where you
were going with that i'm not sure
i don't remember okay let's move on
so we were talking about asian hate
crimes and why the [ __ ] it's even a
thing right now
how is that let's not get into it
anymore because it doesn't have an
answer it's just ignorance it's just
very weird
i think there's always going to be a
wave of ignorance going on yeah i know
but
just specifically at one group and
they're just
targeting like old ladies what the [ __ ]
that is awfully specifically weird i
have no idea
yo today we're gonna go out we're gonna
fight people that can't fight back all
right
uh babies old asian ladies people in
wheelchairs like geo what the [ __ ] is
wrong with people bro they are on the
same email list to go
today's deed of the day what was it like
in a
harold kumar what did you do against an
ethnicity this week
i got to see any guy's toothbrush and
rubbing it on my dick
like that but more violent but more
violent
i [ __ ] hate people so much okay let's
go to this next thing i want to talk
about
um i don't really get into like the
mainstream
music stuff i just keep seeing this
everywhere guys
and um you guys already know what i'm
talking about there's this rapper dude i
don't even know if he's a rapper i guess
you would call him uh
i don't know he's an artist he's an
artist his name is a little nasa
actually hasn't known who i'm talking
about
when he did the uh marty he's the guy
that sang that
uh song that brought white white and
black people together
the old town road song it's like black
guys singing
real swim shady no that one made
them go yeah real but this was like
i like that boy he sings real good he
sounds like a country singer
i guarantee all those ignorant
[ __ ] are like about time
that's hilarious and then they came out
with this go no no we never supported
that
[ __ ] ignorant ass half the people are
that took our job from south park just
mad ignorant homophobic [ __ ]
anyway marty let me update because you i
know you have no [ __ ] clue what's
going on marty because you have
of responsibilities with kids and and a
job so you're not watching uh
this [ __ ] so this little nazix guy for
everyone that doesn't know what's going
on he's super super he got like four
times platinum on that old town road
song last year
then he came out as gay which is a
little [ __ ] obvious which doesn't
who gives a [ __ ] right he just released
a video i haven't even watched the video
because i've only seen clips on twitter
marty he is giving the devil a lap dance
the devil in hell giving him a lap dance
and i haven't even watched the full
video yet guys can we watch some of it
without
you know what i don't want to put that
satanic ass [ __ ] on here
anyway the reason i'm even bringing this
up because i think it's funny i saw a
tweet from him says
all you fools always say uh gays go to
hell but i do go to hell now you're mad
that's [ __ ] comedy yo he knows how to
play to his [ __ ] cause
yo what can piss people off the most
he's a gay black dude
let's sing his contract that sings
country and now
he is like dominatrix outfit in leather
riding on the devil you engage it with
the devil with the devil
with the [ __ ] devil looking like the
devil
i think it's the smartest move ever
because
we're talking about it right now yeah of
course and we don't even give a [ __ ]
and we're talking about it so people
that do care about this industry and
music and this and this are
like either love it or hate it and no
matter what that's what makes everything
right
if you don't have people talking [ __ ]
where's the controversy for it to keep
going
that's why reality shows work i would
love to see that nike meeting where they
had him in there and they were like
yo we're just gonna be a little drunk
just blood
red guys i know blood red vampire [ __ ]
no you haven't seen it it says it has
one drop of human blood in the shoes
marty go back to the news part not the
images go back that's why i brought this
guy up in the first place
i gimmick or not don't like that i don't
like that at all
with human blood whether it's real or
not
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] i don't like
i know people trying to be edgy and
trying to be this and trying to be that
hey [ __ ] i'll be bringing that
[ __ ] into [ __ ] lives making
mass dream [ __ ] satan [ __ ]
[ __ ] you that's
i get it then you just went back to the
asian [ __ ]
japanese internment camps tabs open it
oh yeah jesus dude
well i wanted just to bring that up
wardy because that's what's going on in
the earth right now
you want to look at real hell little
nazaks google merced
internment camps for real you you want
to do some you should just been out
there [ __ ] working
at the [ __ ] what is it the fair see
i've bought
so many shirts from that
some oh it's really sad dude it's really
[ __ ] sad knowing that merced has that
[ __ ]
history jesus christ
um we yeah like i said earlier we just
filmed a vlog and i
we were watching and premiering the
jesuit palusa one
and yeah that's just so funny
she is so [ __ ] funny i'm so glad you
got it right here
me too i knew it that was [ __ ] funny
i knew i was going to be ready oh she's
hilarious
oh man um i just wish we could have seen
john stamos's face when he went on apple
or whatever and first
i saw that thumbnail in the back
him unauthorized no permission i'm
married
i know jessie may's been probably
harassing him for so long
isn't that crazy she's been harassing
him
any other [ __ ] if this is flip this
be all bad
this be all bad like ah she just
that joy got me high as [ __ ] i haven't
smoked weed really today oh yeah i guess
so
i smoked that joint right before you
kill that butterfly yeah
yeah i was i'm telling you that was a
good omen it's symbolic why does he
think it's good
because what are the odds okay we're on
that's like saying
i threw a rock and killed an old lady
what are the odds seriously
no it's not talking about uh guys
a mini drone okay this is like your own
guy this drone is so small it's
technically considered a toy drone
all right you can fly it anywhere this
butterfly committed suicide on it
okay it's not even that guy's it randy
johnson
you were going up fast and it crossed
you not even like it was up there and
you hit it
it it kind of did just go right into the
way oh you're right
you're right murderer but you're right
listen half of its body went flying in
front of the camera
and uh yes he got it on camera you could
see its body in front of the camera it
was so sad
dude i don't think i ever said this on
any story time or anything but i'm just
gonna tell
i won't tell the full story i'll say
what happened one time you guys know
you're from the east coast that
cats and little small animals will try
to get onto your under your car because
it's still hot after you turn it off
you know that that's some impressive
east coast [ __ ] right there yeah it
sounds right well
do you know does it happen in the east
coast uh it's never happened to me but
you've heard of it uh should i have now
i asked you eight different ways you
could have said i've never heard of that
until right now so look um if you guys
don't know
cats uh will go after you turn your car
off right on
at night time it's still hot they'll
crawl underneath
your like axle under your motor or sit
by
where your radiator's at because it's
warm
happens it happens all the time right
one time i'm not gonna tell you the
whole [ __ ] story i'll just tell you
some of it you know i'll tell you the
whole story all right here we go
one time i
i was really high and i lived with my
grandpa
on sixth street still and i was still
working at me and ed so this is like
right when i was like 18 right before i
got my apartment
and um i i'm sad about it still because
it was
really really really sad i
turned my car on i backed up and when i
backed up i heard
like i heard something
what the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] you know
it's my first car is my dodge and treben
my green one the trash ass one
i back out of the driveway and i stop
it's like 11 30 12 at night there's no
cars
anywhere so i just stopped like halfway
in the road
and i get out and i look underneath my
car i'm looking into my car
what the [ __ ] i don't see [ __ ] all right
back out and as i back out my lights
hit like the bottom of the driveway so
now i can see the bottom of the driveway
in the gutter right
because before i couldn't i was like on
the driveway
so as i back out i see and i go what the
[ __ ] is that
i walk out of my car i go over and it's
a [ __ ] cat
that was on my engine block or whatever
and it cut its head clean in half
marty marty there was no top of a skull
brains look just like brains in movies
this cat was dead it's head like
hannibal lecter [ __ ]
no no lie our cat's heads are falling
off
[Laughter]
was it dumb and dumber hate you
so much the only time you could ever use
that reference
ever in life i should not have smoked
that joint so early oh man here we go
it's it's cut directly in half mart
and the brain is out like it's it's
heads like this and the brain's barely
out on like about to fall out but it's
you can see it
and i just and i dry heave real hard and
i burp
i turn around i feel so [ __ ] bad i
hate cats but i feel bad it's still a
cat
some cats are cool and uh
i left to the store
so as i lit all right i'm gonna end up
telling you this whole [ __ ] story
damn it
i back out i go to the store i remember
i'm high and paranoid
because i just killed a cat i feel super
bad i was about to pick it up i was
about to go get something to drink at
the store
it's like remember it's like midnight i
drive
i drive off thinking about like oh my
god this [ __ ] cat
like i'm like this is sad i was feeling
bad
i pull up get my drink and as i come
back
right when i pull out of the [ __ ]
parking lot of the liquor store right
when i pull out
cop right behind me i keep my scale my
pipe my
little tiny steamroller keep bags in my
trunk
because for pizza for pizza [ __ ] like i
keep it stashed underneath my tire
and then when i work for p uh go to work
at me and as i put it all in my pizza
bag
why you should put in a shoe box and
then i put in my pizza bag to sell sex
so i know that's in the trunk i'm high
to where like i i'm noticeable
and you know back then i i just got my
weed car but it doesn't mean you could
be
hey officer and i live in the ghetto i
live in the [ __ ] ghetto my car sucks
the young mexican kid i probably it
probably reeked bad in my car
sure your insurance and your
registration everything was like
everything's always on
always because i'm a pizza delivery
driver i have to be
i have to be perfect yeah no my
drivework is bomb
um until recently [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway uh
i'm doing this one guys oh [ __ ] you know
you're driving you're looking ahead and
you're trying to like not look at the
rear view and you look at it and go pro
[ __ ] you think locked eyes with me
do you think you saw my eyes looking
back because from experience when i look
at somebody in front
i can see their eyes when they look up
so how many times a cop go
all right he looked at me five times in
one block i'm pulling them over
you know they're doing that [ __ ] young
kid it's 12
is he even old enough to try because i
look like a kid now imagine me 18 i look
[ __ ] 12.
so i'm driving back doing this number
[ __ ] oh come on man there's looking
sounds [ __ ] weird
and i'm just thinking of all the things
that are going to happen when i get
pulled over right now and search and
it's merc said whether or not he has the
right to search he's going to search me
and uh he follows me gets gets right but
i remember
i'm only a mile ish away from my house
my grandpa's house
and there's a dead cat right outside the
gutter right outside the gutter
when i put it in park it fell out so
there's a cat with no skull
a brain fallout and it's a dead body
so that's what it was it was crack crack
and it cut its head off so the skull is
probably inside of my car
i i don't care about that at all right
now i think i'm getting pulled over and
i'm done
so i'm driving and i'm like i'm like
just regret thinking about like why did
you take that [ __ ] out
come on why are you gonna be lazy why
don't you just take your scale out you
can always take your scale what the [ __ ]
do you leave in the car today like i'm
going through all these things because i
know i left it in there because i opened
me and ed's in the morning so i knew i
was
just leaving the [ __ ] trunk one of
those you guys know if you sell weed you
guys [ __ ] know that
never take the lazy way out because
that'd be the day you get in trouble
so always never [ __ ] up your routine i
[ __ ] up my routine and let that [ __ ]
in the trunk which i never really do
i never really do i i always have a
shoebox to take it out my backpack put
it in my
in my room i'm so off track anyway
go back i'm pulling the old please don't
pull me over
he follows me i go past right by mike
see his house
my homie i get about three blocks from
my house
you guys never said i get right in front
of the armory the armory that's in
merced i lived
six street six and r i'm about two
blocks away and as i take that right on
s street right when i hit s street the
cop
uh takes the s with me and there's only
one more turn
to my house i get past the park left and
i park
on the right side so he's either gonna
get me and get me at my house too my
grandpa's asleep ready to go to work
wake him up yo you know he should go to
jail right he's scared i was just
thinking like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] right
he follows me all the way to that stop
sign
i look up one more time oh my god please
pull me over here don't wait my grandpa
let me know because then he'll be like
you're going to jail why i just didn't
want the disappointment
i took a left and as he notices i'm like
about to pull into the driveway
he's waiting at that stop he was
eyeballing me he had nothing on me he
ran my [ __ ] just says
see what he does [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
whoever what cop you wear [ __ ] you
i take a left guys remember i'm doing
this
this is all gonna this is all for a
reason all right i'm doing this i'm
looking up at him
and i'm like doing this number about to
pull in my driveway
because i'm like okay go go and he
starts to go as i go i hear
and i go what the [ __ ] i forgot about
the cat
i completely completely completely
forgot about the dead cat in the [ __ ]
driveway
i ran the [ __ ] dead cat over remember
when i said the brain was intact
and it was falling out not after that i
c
marty i ran the cat over fully
cr i never seen crush skull before it's
really disgusting
i saw it i went into the driveway and
went
like [ __ ] dry heave because i i
was looking at like the blood on my tire
the piece of skull in between my tire
i look in the driveway at the end of the
driveway past the gutter
and that [ __ ] is flat smushed
out uh the brains are
everywhere and i went
uh i'm too [ __ ] high to deal with
this right now and i walked in the house
and said i'll pick that [ __ ] up in the
morning
guys i left it right where it was cause
i said
it's night time it's dark i'm gonna miss
some [ __ ]
i'm not done i'm not even was this
somebody's cat
is that there was no color okay well
[ __ ] i mean
and plus why is your cat outside inside
my my engine it wasn't
it wasn't my fault i felt bad it was in
my fan blade that's where the blood was
when i when i opened this [ __ ] in the
morning to look at my car it was like in
the belt
i felt so bad dude pulp fiction i felt
really bad yeah i felt bad but anyway
i'm not done
uh so the cop doesn't pull me over once
he realizes okay he's going into
somewhere he was gonna follow me
until i [ __ ] up yeah piece of [ __ ] and
that's why i was looking back at him in
the rear view like come on come on come
on
as i did it went crack are you [ __ ]
kidding me i really ran you over
i really ran it over are you [ __ ]
serious i couldn't believe it marty
cause it was all
over my car and i'm like oh my god come
on dude
but the cop had me distracted he had me
distracted
so it's morning and i wake up hella late
it's like 11 o'clock i woke up late as
[ __ ] i mean i uh it's like 10 o'clock
i woke up late as [ __ ] because i had to
uh
do the opening shift for me and ed's no
it had to be like nine o'clock thing
because the opening shift starts at 10
30. it had to be like nine o'clock
i woke up late that later than normally
should right
i know that because i remember i rushed
to get ready
it's a small house i look out and my
grandpa's not at work
i'm like oh why aren't you at work i
realize oh it's saturday
you must have the random saturday off
but i open minutes so
i look at this [ __ ] and i go
what's he doing
i'm looking at my grandpa between the
pink plastic blinds and he's just doing
this forrest gump [ __ ]
looking down and go what is he oh the
cat i forgot to clean up the cat
and my grandpa i just see him bend down
and go no no
and i see him just pick up this flat
dripping cat by the tail
he's like that oh his hand with his
[ __ ] hand like this with just the
tail it's not all bloody in the tail but
still
still no still i but i i agree
picture i'm not done pics it up can you
google 1142
west 6th street that's where i grew up
that's my house
1142 west sixth street i wanna i want
you guys to see what my grandpa did
can you google earth it i want you to
see
that's the house i grew up in guys all
right
so see as i went back down the driveway
and i back down you see where that white
piece of paper is in the gutter
right there in the gutters that white
piece of paper about a foot behind it is
where the cat fell out because
i waited till i got out of there and i
put it in park
right i thought you were talking about
some country no
it's a driveway no it was a little
driver so when i went
crack i went what the [ __ ] and i put it
in park
so it fell down right there but the
thing is i parked so when i looked under
i didn't see it
you know it's nighttime okay see that
church
see those planters uh-huh so i see my
grandpa pick up this cat
what is he doing he's doing this oh [ __ ]
he walks across the street you see that
planter to the right
to the right okay that one i watched my
grandpa
walk up and just put the cat just on the
sidewalk
it's not a garbage can we have trash
cans
right there on the side of the house he
put the cat
inside of the planter oh
god the trash cans are outside he could
have just put
he was there for months that's
horrifying i watched it petrified get
petrified yeah
i watched it i smoked bunch right there
that's my soul weed
remember all the story times that pull
up right from my grandpa's right there
is where sang's car used to be the black
one
is where we used to park uh because it's
blocked because my grandpa sits in the
living room to the left
so he can't see me directly outside he
sits right behind that water cooler
that swamp cooler so i would be able to
block us the smoke
cloud but if i was any more to the right
he would just be staring at me smoking a
blunt
and i grew up my first ollie i ever did
was in that parking lot
um that's where i grew up right there
that's crazy
i have so many stores right there so
that reminded me of a story
me and my two boys went deep into the
east side to get some weed one time
we got there and they were like yeah we
just got raided
my boy hopped out and he they told him
yeah they we just got raided like
probably 20 minutes ago they were
already back
on it they sold us weed
okay you mean you got sold we buy
informants
they got raided and didn't go to jail
man there was a [ __ ] pack of them i'm
gonna let you know right now
you got some weed by an aforementioned
all right well [ __ ]
something happened this was my boy's boy
i stayed in the car he hopped out and
talked to these folks
so i'm finding out about this afterwards
he's like oh yeah they just got raided
so actually i convicted the murder ten
minutes ago no i'm good what's up i'm
like
i'm thinking the same [ __ ] like what the
[ __ ] do you mean they just got raided
did you get the weed i was like yeah
they still had some weed
yeah i don't [ __ ] know but anyway as
soon as we pulled out of there they got
behind us
the cops yeah because you're white right
yeah i mean yeah we're just leaving
i'm saying that neighborhood oh because
the house just got real
yeah it was completely secondary in this
equation this was not
racially motivated black dudes
that's that's that's unreal so then we
pull out of the street they're behind us
i'm i'm like this was i used to get
pulled over all the [ __ ] times i
brought it up
yeah in this moment i was like [ __ ] we
just [ __ ] up usually it's not like oh
i
[ __ ] up yeah usually it's just like
these [ __ ] but
now it's like oh [ __ ] my boy behind me
he had been to jail before
like it was he's older than me it wasn't
good
so then now we're going down broadway if
you know anything about buffalo broadway
and bailey
this is where i'm talking about so we're
going down broadway towards bailey
and i'm like i see a kfc in the distance
so i'm like all right we're just going
to turn into this kfc he's dropping
behind us i'm like we're just gonna turn
into the kfc i hit the blinker on
we're going i slow down i go to turn the
[ __ ] kfc is boarded up
so [ __ ] undo the blame bro
as soon as i did that oh he blurbed your
ass because of that
hazard it was just it must i don't know
if he was he was gonna [ __ ] do it
anyway but
of course in that moment and yeah they
pulled their guns out all that [ __ ]
they had they made you get up at
gunpoint yeah are you [ __ ] serious
with no prior anything your car is just
standard
operating procedure i'm talking this was
a forest green escort station wagon this
[ __ ] was my dad's this is the one wait
wait wait wait wait
that's the order operation in buffalo's
get out by gunpoint
[ __ ] if you get pulled over on the east
side there is a good chance you're
getting pulled out of [ __ ] gun point
for sure
what though at least in my experience
once they like pulled my boy's pants
down just on the sidewalk searching all
through his boxers and [ __ ] all in his
pants
my boy sounds racially motivated he was
black hold on
did you get your pants pulled down no
racially motivated marty yeah i'm gonna
take that out you're the dream driver
folks i'm gonna take that one as a win
but you're the driver and they didn't
search you and it's your vehicle
that was racial [ __ ] they might have
i didn't have any wheat on me they might
have that's
did they find the weed no my boy behind
me had the weed in his sock
and he's the one who had gone to jail
before we're talking about like a
[ __ ] 20 sack of some [ __ ] you're
gonna go to jail for that oh for sure
if they find a 20 sacks [ __ ] over
he's been to jail before and the dude
the cops knows it i remember he's like
oh you anybody been to jail before he's
like yeah when i was younger the dude
looks like he's my age but he's
15 years older yeah when i was young and
stupid i went and i'm as soon as he said
that i'm like oh it's [ __ ] over
oh yeah they're searching they didn't
search him
really the weed in a sock they did not
search him i remember he had a clear
clear block you remember clear blunts uh
[ __ ] yes
that's the first time i had ever seen it
at the enterprise adventure you gave me
one in a clear blunt and [ __ ] i was like
clear blunts oh i brought it back to
portland when i moved yeah but that was
standard though they would they
will [ __ ] take you over to jail and
pull the guns out over the
most minute i've heard horror stories
man about illegal states dude
this is perfect marty let's play this
right here let's be right into the next
note what's up from new york what's up
everybody in new york i don't know is it
fully legal now it's going to be they
passed it we're like yeah crazy make it
federally uh
what is it is it is it legal like they
can have up to an ounce like
us i think it's like that you can grow
it it's recreational we're talking like
a year from now
like they passed it so that it will
happen yo new york
[ __ ] mind-boggling congratulations
marty marty
your home state you're gonna be able to
go home and get high now
if you ever have to go back you can go
to the dispensary get weed
it's insane that's insane that's [ __ ]
incredible that's all the whole story
in my life when i lived there like it
made me hate the cops it made me hate a
lot of [ __ ] people just having just
to get weed
yeah they made me feel like [ __ ]
criminal when i was a good person
just for weed i was look at my path now
what they would have put me in jail for
this [ __ ]
what look what happened yeah it's
[ __ ] stupid
so i just not to mention the fact that
it's a poor ass ghetto ass city that
could
have a whole industry built around it
like it is here
and people could get off the pills
enough to alcohol
i mean i get it from pharmaceutical
standpoint they want people on pills
because they can sell them a different
pill because this pill
[ __ ] him up i get it it's a money
thing it's it's a coke dealer [ __ ] it's
crackhead [ __ ]
i get it but come on man at least let us
[ __ ] weed smokers we weren't
gonna take your pills anyway
at least let us have our own [ __ ] i
don't i'll ne i won't even get into it
because you guys know how i feel it's
just
it's [ __ ] stupid but marty new york
i mean how [ __ ] cool it doesn't even
feel real yet but it will when i
that shouldn't be crazy when i go back
that's going to feel crazy
just as a human like it's like a human
rights thing it is a human rights thing
because it's medicine
you're not it's medicine it's medicinal
so what the [ __ ] yeah you're not allowed
to
[ __ ] kidnap me and extort me out of
my money for nothing
uh like that was real obvious to me as a
19 year old and it really [ __ ] pissed
me off that everybody just accepted that
as okay normally that's
that's the way it is move california if
you don't like it yeah that's pretty
much the way it is over there well not
anymore
yeah yeah but it's even worse because
like like i said my dad had cancer for
like eight years and it was eight years
of
he's gonna die for sure no he's not
gonna die okay no he is gonna die
definitely
okay no he's not gonna die okay he is
gonna die it happened
so many times and he was on so many
medicines and surgeries and all this
[ __ ] and all the man wanted to do was
smoke weed
casually minus business they would have
arrested his ass for that
yeah they were really 100 that was like
yeah that's what you get arrested just
as easy as you would have
oh for sure cause they'll just i mean
you know how it is they would pull you
over just just kind of for fun just on
some yeah just
like like that was doing to me yeah like
yeah he was just
my shit's perfect yeah my driving
record's great i work for me and ed's
still following me he checked my [ __ ] a
mile ago the [ __ ] you still following
for
i realize that they're bored too like
the one time yeah
think about it though yeah i got cuffed
and put in the back seat and [ __ ] and
they had this heavy metal blasting in
the cop car
yeah and at first i was like ooh this is
creepy these three dudes are [ __ ]
three guys in the cop car in the front
one right there might have been two
it would cars been funny there was three
cops there was at least one car
but it had heavy metal blaring on the
inside of it no it's gaming and then i
realized like
oh this is their night they're riding
around just like [ __ ] with people
yep that's really what it was and at the
end of it i'm like
they i mean i was good they let me go uh
but um the way i like to think about
cops is
i hope all of them are like the super
bad cops they put on a scary front go
come on man we're just like you just
stop being a dick don't run
we'll help you come on that's how i hope
most cops
are like the cops that are being dicks
to you like yo i win 20 bucks right i
just get the [ __ ] out of the kid
you know that that's that's more of like
okay
all right but once you start giving
people extra charges and more time
because you
feel like it then you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah you're no longer super bad or if
you
if you're super tough out there in the
street and you're pulling people over
and doing all this [ __ ] but then you're
too
scared to come to the court date about
it that was my [ __ ]
that was my [ __ ] yeah i had to show up a
couple times where they would
pull some [ __ ] like that on me then i
would go in and start
halfway [ __ ] spazzing on the people
in the county hall
to the point that my mom was like you
need to chill the [ __ ] out and just sit
down and just
and then the dude didn't come it
happened like two or three times how
many times you get in trouble marty i
just get pulled over all the [ __ ] oh
this is for getting pulled over [ __ ]
yeah
okay okay that's that's different damn
you're driving right because you're
insurance high as [ __ ] like yo you're
just as suspicious i never got arrested
i never got there yo that color man
actually that color got your ass they're
like oh we thought you were tweaker when
we got up close we noticed you're a
basketball player
yeah basically go on son get that
scholarship yeah
basically that that is what was
happening i know
they look at you like i like the color
you i like your color
continue yeah once i stopped going
against
once i stopped having that just hate in
my heart towards them
it i i don't know what it was i stopped
getting pulled over as much
i stopped once i don't know i used to go
out i guarantee you mean mug the [ __ ]
out of cops got pulled over
yeah my attitude probably did have a lot
a lot to do with it i do this
i'm not kidding
when cops are next to me or behind me
like anywhere with buildings i always go
look at this architecture
i always do it never get pulled over
because my car is always full of small
i mean i should shut the [ __ ] up i gotta
stop [ __ ] just saying [ __ ]
when i'm not driving sometimes i'd like
to smoke marijuana in my car
cbd there you go cbd
smoke my [ __ ] is squeaky clean and i
still feel like i'm gonna [ __ ]
because you're from the east coast man
yeah you're from the [ __ ] east coast
you're never gonna wear that
it's not gonna wear off until you pull
up and an officer goes
nice car uh-huh and the day they do that
you're like you ain't [ __ ] like my mom
punched me in the face and i was like
[ __ ] that's it yeah yeah you know what
actually i don't know if i've ever
talked about that story i really talked
about uh
i haven't really talked about this too
much i think i told it on story time
um but real quick let me get into
something marty real fast because
uh you guys talk i read all the comments
i try to answer
every single comment and you guys know
that so
i keep constantly getting how come you
don't take dabs
how can you not [ __ ] uh uh hitting
rosin or hitting pens or
how come you don't even smoke the bongs
you sell [ __ ] like that
you guys got to remember um
youtube monetize this channel i do not
want to get kicked out i don't want to
get kicked off
that's it i don't and we're monetized i
don't want them to go hey you know what
we don't like that you were hitting a
bong on your [ __ ] channel no more
money
that's what i don't want to [ __ ]
happen okay guys that's that's my
my ultimate goal is to not get in
trouble so
that being said hey if anybody from
youtube is viewing this and going hey we
don't like that
joe rogan joey diaz smoke bongs on their
huge
millions and millions and millions of
views channel they are no different from
me
they're no different from anybody else
they're human beings that smoke weed
and they also get on the internet so why
just pinpoint me with that being said
i'm going to do the rare bong hit
on the on the uh on the podcast because
i just don't want to risk it if you want
to see more weed and more [ __ ] follow my
instagram my snapchat
follow my twitter go to dopaziolo.com of
oh belle ball eval
jesus i even hit the ball yet you got
excited for that new website
above all else go to dopaziola.com
it is so bomb it it looks so
[ __ ] sick it is awesome so go
go to dopeysolo.com guys become a site
member become a site member it's
[ __ ] free you can see every single
thing that comes every single [ __ ]
everything is on there the podcast dope
as usual dope
everything so go ahead and check that
out dopazio.com
i'm posting pictures that i can't post
on instagram posting a picture can't
post anywhere else
the reason i bring that up is because
like i said i'm gonna do the rare bong
hit
but not just a regular bong i want you
got
let me tell you a little story real
quick before i even bust it out
a couple years ago you guys saw seth
rogen was hitting uh
like some weird globe bong you guys
remember that
that video of seth rogen hitting some
super stale smoke
like really stale smoke it like built up
for [ __ ] 30 minutes and then he
started dying because it was still
and i felt so bad for him like yo that
thing looks so confusing
this one is yellow he smokes yellow
because he took too long that smoke
tastes disgusting i guarantee
and i feel bad like oh man that [ __ ]
tastes bad
because i know that pain you get that
rip in your throat so
the reason i bring this up i saw that
video and go what is this machine
so months later i'm at the cannabis cup
i'm just walking around filming doing my
thing
and i see this thing on a table shout
out to trey i see this thing on a table
right and i'm like that's the thing just
seth rogen hit
can i can i hit this [ __ ] thing and
you don't have to put your mouth on it i
don't care it's pretty covered anyway
i didn't care about hitting it because i
had to put my mouth on it goes yeah you
can hit it
and there's two of them i go hey uh can
i hit him both at the same time
he's like you think he can do that i'm
like yeah i'm pretty sure i could do
that man
and i started smoking at him i recorded
it and those videos
that's like three accounts ago those
videos popped like a couple hundred
thousand views on them because people
that follow my [ __ ] were like yo what is
this [ __ ]
what is this machine so the reason i
bring it up is because
over the course of years i finally got
to do a review and i was the first
review to do it and youtube took it off
they literally just xed out that video
deleted that video and gave me a strike
don't know why it's just a regular
gravity bomb um
so the reason i'm saying that is
everybody that's watching this youtube
this is the rare bong hit video but like
i said i want to do a crazy
i want to i want to show you something
you don't see every day so this is a
student in glass shout out to trey the
owner um they came through my house
gave me a demonstration and we made a
[ __ ] sick video so it's on the dope
yola channel
this right here is a gravity bomb the
only reason i'm gonna
i'm saying the rare hit because you're
probably not gonna see too many more
bong hits i don't want youtube getting
upset with me alright
i want to stay in their good standings
so this is the student in glass
we are not sitting here advertising go
buy this nothing like that
so youtube don't be pissed at me hey if
you got to do that you got to get mad
joey diaz and joe and uh
joe rogan because they smoke bongs too
so don't be nitpicking [ __ ]
uh for everybody at home this thing
looks like uh
a spaceship there's nothing else to say
but stunning glass i have
one two three four five i have [ __ ]
four or five of these i've given away
like four to my friends just to
spread it around they're just fun
they're just fun i love using it
it's really fun cool but like i said for
everyone out there on the podcast this
is the rare bong hit all right now i
said that 62 times but i'm also [ __ ]
ranting
let's hit this real quick here we go
oh you little bastard but yeah i've done
multiple reviews on it guys
you've seen this on my channel many
times i have a custom story time orange
and push trees one i just blew my smoke
[ __ ]
uh yeah i just want to bust it out
because a regular bong hits a regular
might as well go a little fancy right
here we go
oh marty i'm high
i just went like this my mouth is on the
microphone bro
[Laughter]
oh no no if any of my family's watching
this
i'm sorry i'm not stupid i promise
you're a podcast legend
yo if it worked i would be here we go i
almost did it again
so here we're just going to let this
build up like i said it's like a science
project
it's like the gravity bongs in your uh
bathtubs except
not disgusting that's it
i'm gonna pull this [ __ ] go to
town
for everyone listening on spotify
streaming platforms you just missed some
fun
but that was [ __ ] cool every time
i've had this for two years i think it's
cool
every [ __ ] time and this is still
smoke
you two don't be getting pissed all
right don't be getting pissed
[ __ ] i've seen fools take dmt on
podcast don't be getting mad at me
please please don't get mad
all right let's walk one more ball out
of this and then uh we'll get into the
story
the reason i wanted to smoke out of this
is because people keep asking
and before the podcast gets bigger and
we get flagged even harder
i wanted to show you guys some cool bong
some cool
smoking because like i said we're not
going to do more of it
we can't i just don't want to risk the
podcast i don't want to risk the channel
people that don't know about weed are
like what the [ __ ] is that thing
yes it's a gravity bomb you guys ever
seen when people um
cut like a soda bottle two liter in half
right they cut a two liter in half put a
bowl the top burn it suck it through and
there's hell of smoke and you push down
the smoke shoots out
this is a gravity bomb just a fancy one
this is just an adult gravity bomb right
once you get past the college age you
should have one of these in your house
in your home yo we're just talking about
that you guys remember that
are there magpies in your home do you
remember that commercial that cartoon
nah the old school cartoon is there a
magpie in your home
i love that one it's the looney tunes
one i believe
is there a no don't look at magpies
magpie cartoon
i didn't know magpie was a species of
bird is there a magpie in your home
that one of the black and white in the
middle down with a nest
that's it heckle and jekyll that's their
name they were dicks and they drove this
dog insane
such a good cartoon i love that cartoon
shout out to anybody that knows what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about
1946 there was definitely some racism in
that cartoon never mind
i need to go back and watch it again
before i over here suggesting this [ __ ]
the talking magpies yeah i loved woody
woodpecker you guys remember the one
where the
the fools didn't harvest i had the 100
greatest cartoons on tape
see magpie hotel no vacancy [ __ ]
sorry for getting off topic let's hit
this bonding you can get into what we're
talking about we're over here watching
cartoons
hey man welcome to the dopes usual
podcast we're here to talk about ranting
nothing problems
alcohol uh my memory loss
we're here to talk about nothing we're
here to talk about nothing
we're gonna piss you off in your car
because you can't keep us [ __ ] plot
going
here for the vods folks
you know rogan didn't start smoking weed
so he was like 30 something right
for real yeah jesus
i mean good for him should he save some
money
all right i'm gonna put this on the
ground because i know i know for sure
i'm gonna be talking and go well in 1999
and i'm gonna break my brand new [ __ ] so
i'll put that [ __ ] on the ground
we'll hit it later on okay see these are
the early days of rogan
uh getting introduced by eddie bravo let
[ __ ] look like justin long
with a beard i can't sit
indian style only [ __ ] that
stretch and do karate can do that [ __ ]
well that's eddie bravo for sure wow he
had a lot of hair
yeah he looks like the dude from hoover
stink do you know who that is
uh no it's a band you should look up
hooba stank they sing that uh
do host you asked me no
look at this eddie bravo had a set of
[ __ ] hair no he looks
baller like that he looks like he's
gonna [ __ ] eat you like in lost boys
like he's gonna
bite into your [ __ ] sick you should
look up uh well he didn't really start
smoking until his 30s yeah
i mean that's cool he was just a
straight up yeah just an
athlete that's cool that's cool [ __ ] it
it looks like a rock club dude it'll
choke your life out
that's awesome his hair is bomb yeah he
looks like a rock star
yo uh so yeah that's why we don't take
bong hits on here
because we don't want to get in trouble
all right so
uh marty what time are we at right now i
wanna i wanna hour 15. hour 15.
oh [ __ ] i'm sorry guys rambled for an
hour and 15 minutes here we go
[Music]
manscaped it's usually for your dick
[Music]
what's up guys so if you couldn't tell
already we are now doing
manscaped ads [ __ ] welcome to our very
first manscaped ad read guys i know
like you you guys know this before we
got an adree we got a sponsorship we
are going to do a little commercial we
want to do cinematics we want to do
more stuff so yes this could be a
regular one-minute ad read but we
decided to show you that little
gillette commercial [ __ ] going on
just because it was fun you guys have
been following for a long time so for us
to
actually get a brand an actual good
brand that i've seen before i
know this brand on every other podcast
so thank you guys for making that
possible that doesn't happen without the
fans the interaction the numbers
the the views so thank you guys for
letting this be possible so if you don't
know what this is this is for
pubic hair basically let me break it
down for you for all the dudes out there
that like
advertisement that's directly [ __ ]
hilarious this is it when i open the box
it says
your balls will thank you that is some
[ __ ] that i can relate to that is
[ __ ] funny so we're doing a trial
campaign with manscaped we're just doing
it because we're such a brand new
company that they can't
fully give us a you know a whole
contract so this is what i need from you
guys
if you want to support the podcast and
you want to make your girlfriend a
little bit happier and you guys click
the link in the description
that is to manscape use our code our
code is y-o-l-a it's yola
use that code you get 20 off and free
shipping it doesn't get any [ __ ]
better than that guys click that link
help us out if you were going to buy
this [ __ ] already
now is the time use our code help us out
that'd be [ __ ] awesome and how odd
marty right before
right before we started this ad i called
my friend justin and i showed him oh
we're doing a manscape daddy goes
what i'm about to buy manscaped right
now because i
nicked my [ __ ] balls the other day
and i said never again he's like i saw
dad on the tv and i said
i'm buying that [ __ ] and he asked me for
the code the codexiola
so organically we already got our first
[ __ ] sale
so thank you guys so much thank you for
our first ad read slash commercial it
was fun as [ __ ] to film
thank you guys so much for being a part
of this manscape shout out to you for
supporting the podcast
thank you guys so much for watching back
to the episode
ready i'm going to tell the story i
wanted to
tell this story for you and that's why
we brought it up earlier about my mom
so you guys if you don't know story time
get [ __ ] ready because this is about
to get wild
and it's a couple stories in one so here
we go
sicily 1942 god [ __ ] golden girls is
such a good movie
all right ready i was like 15 years old
right
uh my mom i know people like you
shouldn't talk about your mother like
that
well maybe you shouldn't talk about your
mother like that all right my mom was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] when i was younger she was
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] jerk to me not all
the time
and i know she's there watching she
watches all the podcasts i know mom
she's texting me right now i already
know she texts me
if you're a [ __ ] dick hey you should
you're lucky you're lucky that's all i
say and let's all i do is talk [ __ ]
about the
facts that happen [ __ ] i'm not
elaborate i'm not like
embellishing [ __ ] this is exactly what
happened
you know and as soon as she gets mad she
starts changing the subject go don't
change the subject tommy
shut up all those years she was being a
dick never in her wildest dreams
i feel evil and petty and i love it
it's like all right you know what that's
the payback i get to talk about it to
earth
everybody gets to know your wrongdoing
it's a lifeless be nice to your kids
don't talk [ __ ] to girls at school if
you don't know their dads might check
you
what else do we learn today don't sign
your way to life away to the devil
like a little nas um and don't be racist
pretty wholesome podcast that's really
good podcast no devil no racism
talk [ __ ] about your mom if you want we
sat here and we did oh did this
butterfly for a good 20 minutes that was
so sad
all right let's get back into the store
that was sad that was sad i feel bad
here we go damn it marty all right
at this time my mom was a [ __ ] i was
15.
i really did not want to go to school
i get it she has every right to be upset
with me about the school thing
all right when i was younger my mom my
dad got damned never
married they were they broke up when i
was like three
four so my mom dated different people
here and people that you've heard of the
white supremacist asked me i'mma set his
name
one day i'ma [ __ ] up we're gonna have to
bleep that [ __ ] out i almost said his
name my step dad you guys have heard
that
we probably haven't heard that story mom
was married to white supremacist for a
while
and it's really [ __ ] stupid i know it
sounds dumb but
it's real we they did just hear this
last episode
yeah they didn't hear about it at all
okay anyway
uh boyfriend here boyfriend there as i
got older you know
you right now [ __ ] if you're at
home right now and you can
you can like relate to this you feel me
so much right now
when you're younger and your dad's not
there and your mom starts dating
somebody this is the look you give
anybody she dates
what's up man once you start getting a
little older like
what's up what's your name like that's
how you feel like
do i have to whoop your ass and when i
was younger when i was younger dude
i was rocked out i was a fat kid but i
was strong as [ __ ] we've
been over this i was in the
weightlifting competition type
kid i was a little [ __ ] anyway uh my
mom
was dating people real cool there's this
black dude his name was rent
i don't know why his name was rent his
name was a huge long name but his
nickname was rent and i go that's a
really dumb name and then we were
watching the
simpsons episode and homer's like that's
only like with losers that have a cat
and live in a one-bedroom apartment by
themselves
and he had a one-bedroom apartment and
he only lived with his cat and i felt so
bad like he's not a loser he's nice but
he just felt hella stupid because my mom
laughed at his face
anyway mom dated that guy totaled this
car on the way to casino and i think
they just never talked again
um my mom dated a bunch of different
dudes and
i was getting older so like i said every
time someone walks in you're like
who's this [ __ ] all right man
what's your name yeah
cool yeah yeah you like sports yeah
don't try to relate to me man date my
mom don't try to get cool with me it's
so creepy
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] hairdresser
especially
the second dude the third i hated it
i did not go through this [ __ ] but
you're lucky man it's the
work and for every boy out there girls
it's bad too
for every boy out there you guys [ __ ]
feel me it is like
on some baby boy [ __ ] except being
raised
i dated my mom and i will [ __ ] up any
[ __ ] that dated my mom back then
so it's like i was a kid i was like 11
so i'm like ugh all right [ __ ] you
yeah you're nice until they proved me
wrong until they didn't admit
you know what i mean unless you were
cool i didn't [ __ ] with you
and uh my mom started dating this dude
named jimbo
and he's a little [ __ ] [ __ ] and
he's a [ __ ] there's a bunch of [ __ ] he
did that i didn't know about
until i got older and i'm like what the
[ __ ] i would have knocked that phone his
ass right then and there
anyway he might be a really nice person
and my mom was a dick to him so i can't
hold it against him i don't know the
situation
but back then he was to me i was like
[ __ ] this fool
um you know what let me let me revert
real quick a month let me go back two
weeks prior
mom yeah i'm airing your [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ]
my mom a guy walks in the house and i'm
like
who the [ __ ] are you it's just me my
sister and my little brother rocco he
was a year old at the time
oh who the [ __ ] is this nerd that's why
i thought like you [ __ ] nerd
i don't know why i thought that but he
walked in just his vibe i was like
i'm gonna push you on the ground i was
like 13
right i was like 13 years old i was a
kid uh no i was 14 i was 14.
i was smoking weed already yep it was 14
it was the story time where i smoked joy
and fell asleep
yeah i was like 14 going on 15. and this
guy walks in and then my mom walks in a
couple seconds after so that's
like who the [ __ ] are you walking in the
house but my mom was with him but i
didn't see her at the time because she
was still coming around the corner
still it's not your house the person who
lives there open the door
i get it maybe he's trying to be nice
and cordial like oh here open the door
for you who's this [ __ ] kid
anyway i walked in like what's up man
who are you
and my mom introduced him to me he tried
to be like oh hi
man i'm like okay at least you're trying
to be nice i never hold that against a
guy
you're trying to be nice i get it i get
it right now you might be dating
somebody and their son's doing that to
you
you [ __ ] deserve it all right this is
the situation you're getting in bear
through it if you're serious all right
you have to pass the test
30 seconds in marty look at me real
quick you ready you ready
are you ready for what this man told me
all right hell yeah i knew your mom i
knew your mom in high school
like we were friends mine was yeah
that's my mom's thing i've known him
forever
that doesn't [ __ ] matter i don't care
sorry the reason i'm saying that because
like yo can you just stop bringing them
to the house
just stop introducing dudes i don't know
in my [ __ ] living room where i'm
trying to chill with my little brother
and [ __ ] like
i don't want these strangers in the
[ __ ] house [ __ ] go to on it go on a
date
go on a date go to his house if you get
killed get killed at his house
don't get [ __ ] kill my little brother
here like i had no
i had no [ __ ] heart for my mom back
then i was like if you're gonna get
kidnapped get kidnapped outside the
house so my little brother doesn't get
kidnapped too
like that was my only thing like rocco
you good i don't give a [ __ ] what
happened to you that's how i felt back
then cause me and her were just like
i could see why my dad and her used to
fist fight all right i could see
why my dad used to go hey god and punch
my mom i'm not i'm not saying
beat your wife in any way it's just my
funny way of
things i'm going about it like
i would never punch my mom but as she
said stuff to me and go
my dad's got a short temper than me i
could see why you guys were fistfighting
each other because that was
mean why would you act like that like
i'm 15
14 i'm telling you like act your [ __ ]
age
so anyway let's go off the topic of my
dad's domestic abuse and me
okaying it which i'm not doing all right
i asked her can you not bring guys to
the house she did it multiple times like
yo can you stop introducing random man
random
it wasn't all the time my mom's not a
hull or anything it was like
a like three she would go on like three
different dates like every
couple months in that time like not a
lot i get it
she was younger i get her kids are now
old enough to where they can watch the
baby and she's like okay cool
also you won't even get into that
never mind um i'm there and the guy 30
seconds in marty you ready for what he
tells me all right
he goes hey i knew your mom in high
school yeah we're friends your dad beat
the [ __ ] out of me
that doesn't make you feel a lot better
no because yeah your dad beat the [ __ ]
out of me
and i wanted to go yo that's me too
i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you like
the way he said it he was just like
yeah your dad beat my ass like no way
chest bump like he thought that was
going to like make it bond
yeah your dad beat the [ __ ] out of me
and i
and then i go huh and my mom's standing
there like
excuse me like oh they're getting along
like
[ __ ] what's his name
what's this man's name that's telling me
my my dad
beat the [ __ ] out of him so that used to
be my mom's friend like
like 16 candles or appearing pink she
was just like that was ducky
right but he liked my mom so he would
hit on my mom
subtly and my dad picked up on that [ __ ]
and my dad
caught him alone at the mall with my mom
just walking around before cell phones
so my dad just sees my mom with this
dude that he knows tries to hit on my
mom
and my dad mopped his ass in the mall
marty
in front of everybody in security didn't
stop it they just let my dad beat this
man's
head yeah your dad beat the [ __ ] out of
me yeah i
was and he's like just playing like yeah
he [ __ ] me up i was on the like
why are you so proud of this man it's
scary to let it go down
why are you telling his son that's
looking at you like this
looking like the same age you got your
ass whooped by his dad
my dad was only a year older at the time
like
dude he said it like yeah i got like a
450 like big
ss super charger in my backyard yeah
your dad yeah you're working with him
molested me too like damned what else
happened
she just let my dad beat the [ __ ] at you
anyway
20 years later 15 years later here he
comes to try to date my [ __ ] mom
so didn't learn his contract he didn't
learn his [ __ ] lesson all right
didn't learn his [ __ ] lesson at all
um
i just like okay cool and i went in my
room next morning i come out and my mom
and that [ __ ] dude are on the living
room like my makeshift bed like
this [ __ ] slept at the house and
i see my little brother asleep he's like
a year old asleep next to my mom
i just see this dude with no [ __ ]
shirt
i see my mom i see my little brother and
i just like
stomp this [ __ ] out but it's not
his fault
that's why i couldn't do it it's not his
fault he he finally gets to date the
girl he was in love with in high school
the guy that used to whoop his ass is no
longer in the picture
he won he won he won he won
right but now he's got to deal with your
mom though not even that
i i was like that hulkamania
i didn't know what to do because i was
like bruce lee drop kick his ass jump up
and crush him
do something i'm like you know it's not
his fault though high five bro
for you i guess ugh but like in a sense
of a movie like the nerd finally won
he got to like spend the night at the
girl he's always loves house type [ __ ]
[ __ ] you mom first off we're bringing
some [ __ ] man you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh she's gonna be so mad this episode
and then uh
my mom wakes up as i'm i'm shaking and
[ __ ] my mom wakes up and looks and goes
and as she talks coat and i just walked
to my room and that was
what started the downfall i remember i
wasn't mad that he was there
i was mad that my little brother was
right there i was [ __ ] heated
actually i i didn't know what to do i
just wanna like i'm gonna kick both of
your [ __ ] and pick his ass up
and
go to the other room i was just mad like
don't expose a little brother this [ __ ]
he doesn't even know his ass why the
[ __ ] is he here
go to his house [ __ ] i'll watch him
yeah right i was trying to be like i'll
be responsible for you go
anyway that's what started the downfall
and then real soon after that
she started dating this guy named jimbo
whether he's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] he did
some dumb [ __ ]
anyway he did some dumb [ __ ] to michael
john i didn't know about till ten years
later i'm like oh i would have [ __ ]
killed that [ __ ]
anyway it's some stupid [ __ ] she started
dating that guy and i asked her
mom please stop bringing people over
here i even asked her don't bring people
over here
and walks this [ __ ] dude day later
with her and i go
come on man you can't just go on a date
somewhere
you had to bring him here and he walked
in to shake my hand and go bro it's not
even your fault but [ __ ]
like don't oh care package
some hate they're dropping off a lot of
hate and
and rage so he walks in i'm like yeah
it's not even your fault man but now i'm
good
and i just like walked away my mom's all
you better be [ __ ] respect my get the
[ __ ] out of here i remember i cussed and
she didn't beat my ass and that's when i
knew like
this is the turning point you just
slipped up
yeah i said some [ __ ] to you and you
didn't bomb on me because you're trying
to be
look like you don't [ __ ] whoop my ass
in front of your new boyfriend
i've known him forever i knew i'm in
high school
[ __ ] [ __ ] facebook in myspace this
is what you guys did
coco coco space or whatever my mom used
to use that dumbass dating app and i
remember like
you know this is pissing me off she's
gonna hate me
she's gonna hate this so much i don't
give a [ __ ] anyway
it's all leading up to this you guys
ready damn that was like
25 minutes of lead up to just to start
my story god
god they call it the anti-hero you
painted the whole picture
god here we go are you ready i uh
it was a hot sicily 1942 it was a hot
ass day and my mom's on mow the lawn so
i said okay
because i listened to my mom i go
outside
lawnmower will not start i'm strong as
[ __ ] i pull that [ __ ] 32 times
nothing happens i check the gas check
the oil we're all good nothing's working
i leave the llama or out there i'm like
okay i'm gonna leave it out there so
when she gets home she sees that i tried
should start like screaming at me right
away and i can explain that it's not
working
you know i'm trying i'm trying to take
the precautions of like let's let's be
preempt like what do you call it
preemptive right preemptive
damn why my brain just like how do you
say it
and uh you're like a foreigner there how
you saying how you say uh
nice to meet you and i i do all that
and my mom storms in the [ __ ] house
an hour later
screaming at me and she's more mad than
normal i think it's because i got so
pissed that she was bringing that
[ __ ] dude and embarrassed her ass
i also that day when i was like [ __ ] you
and i walked to that in the room i got
some like my shoes on i went to joe's i
walked right out the house
you're not going anywhere and i kept
walking that's when i knew like oh you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
you broke it you let it go you should
have you should have slack
you should have smacked the [ __ ] out of
me and stabbed me right then and there
in the leg just to teach me some [ __ ]
but she didn't
so it's a couple days later the llama
incident happens she walks in starts
[ __ ] going hard like
going hard instantly like gets up close
to me when she never really does like
tries to like punk me and i looked at
her like oh this is
over you don't know it yet but you
[ __ ] up yesterday
all right and uh and i'm telling her the
lawnmower won't work
if you can get it to start i'll do it i
can't get it to start
you're being [ __ ] lazy you're being
[ __ ] lazy go do it [ __ ] you go do it
oh [ __ ] she's mad and i told her
i did this one which something you
should never do to angry ass lady i went
and i started to smile i went i can't
get it
started and i put my hands up like the
international
[ __ ] you that's why i do it i can't get
it started and i smiled
and that was the first time i should i
didn't do this i
i couldn't get it started ah like i was
scared of my mom my whole life
so she saw that and she pushed me in the
chest she goes get out there and [ __ ]
do it and i go i can't do it i'm not
gonna do it
and she got she started screaming at me
again and i went all right this is it
this is the time let's [ __ ] see what
happened i started [ __ ] like
and internally i was like [ __ ]
jogging and doing stretches and [ __ ]
getting ready to [ __ ] rumble
with this [ __ ] lady inside but
outside i'm just
if you can get being a piece of [ __ ] i
just said [ __ ] it
and she went i told her i'm not [ __ ]
doing
it and then she just went like this
she pulled her arm her fist back i saw
her put her fist back and went
oh it's not open and she's gonna punch
me this time all in slow motion she goes
and she punches me right here in the
face
with everything she got and it did this
and my head went back and i went
internally i'm gonna tell you guys step
by step what happened internally i'm
like
don't get knocked out don't let her get
knocked don't let her knock you because
i've all
heard seeing her do is scare me to death
i think my mom's got mike tyson
right hooks apparently she's knocked my
dad unconscious right
so i'm like okay
here it comes take that [ __ ] and outside
i don't even put my hands up i like
put my chin up to take it so i can show
her like [ __ ] you
like i just wanted her to see like it's
over
like my sister when she [ __ ] snatched
my playstation pieces like it was it
like this is the day now i'm talking
about my mom i'm talking about my mom
she's scarier than my sister
um as she connects boom
internally i'm like scrambling like no
no
no are we good are we wait we're good
what the [ __ ] and outside i went are you
[ __ ]
serious that's why i yelled at are you
[ __ ] serious
that's it i thought she i know she
thought like
yeah i'm serious and i was old that's it
and i yelled at
it all my insides like nah bro we're 100
good to go talk [ __ ] we're no you're not
gonna
you're not even [ __ ] wobbling your
knees are strong and i looked here and
go
are you [ __ ] serious that's it and
she looked at me and she likes went to
sweat and i put my hands up like oh
that's it she punched me with everything
she had in her life and it didn't even
move my body it just knocked my head
back a little bit and then
right when i started laughing and i go
are you serious i would go i was like
i've always been afraid
of you're gonna knock me out and that's
all you [ __ ] got
i was like um wrestler and this [ __ ]
sunday
this is what the [ __ ] we're going to do
that's what i was doing you [ __ ]
hit me again it doesn't [ __ ] matter
it doesn't matter
and i was telling her get out of my way
i'm [ __ ] leaving
no and she goes get the [ __ ] out of my
house right now and i go get out of my
way
i'll [ __ ] leave but she was in the
way of my room
i was like i'm getting my stuff shows no
everything you have there's my no it's
not
i bought most of that [ __ ] as i told
like i bought most of that
[ __ ] and working what the [ __ ]
no you didn't
it always makes me feel like a good
parent here in these stories yeah
continue
sorry and and uh oh she's mad
and and then i look at she looks at me
you're not [ __ ] getting anything and
i go try to stop me and i look down and
go
try to stop me and i can see you look on
her face of like
i'll [ __ ] kill you that's how she
looked at me and she stood my way and i
sort of started walking like this
and she i'm strong as [ __ ] i just
started walking like some
simpsons [ __ ] if you're in the way of my
fists that is your fault
that's how i thought i put my hands up
like this like get out of my way get out
of my way oh you're gonna stop me
can you stop me i went in my room she
got out of my way like five feet down
the hallway
screaming at me i mean
she was screaming at me hard and then uh
so what happened what happened was
i got my shoes those pair of osiris's
they had red on them i remember
everything i picked them up
put them on got some of my clothes i was
like [ __ ] man
i really wanted all my packers stuff
she's really gonna throw all my [ __ ]
away i know she's gonna throw it away
that's why i kept thinking like she's
so petty that she's she's gonna do
something i've been saving this packer
stuff my whole life
[ __ ] but i couldn't take it i only had a
backpack
so i grabbed some of my stuff i put my
backpack on
i walk out the door and she's standing
at the end of the hallway and i just
start
dying laughing because i'm like thinking
of all the years
uh it's like uh um the home alone when
he finally realizes that the broiler
downstairs is not really a monster and
it's just a [ __ ] furnace
and i'm not afraid of you anymore that's
how i felt
when i saw her at the end of the
driveway like oh you're just an
old man that lost his daughters and
talked to him like in the home alone
like
oh you're not scared you're just an old
man oh that's how i felt like oh you're
just a lady
you can't knock me out [ __ ] you so i saw
her
standing there at the back of the
[ __ ] hallway all backlit and [ __ ]
so she all silhouette like [ __ ] clint
eastwood and i walked by
and just yes yes and for some reason i
felt like i got taller
and i look better like
i looked at my little brother my and i
looked at shireen
and she was like not on my side and i'm
thinking
[ __ ] one of us won and you're not on my
side
[ __ ] you and i walked out the door
walked to uh i walked to joe's
through the mud got my shoes all muddy i
was pissed
right behind walmart and and uh um
oh yeah right behind walmart i can't
remember the [ __ ] street anyway
i walk to joe's and that's gonna that
that's what happened i got kicked out
i got kicked out no longer live with my
mom and for the
dope as usual clips channel purposes
that's the end of that story
and then i'm gonna tell you the rest of
the story so we can go beep and do two
separate clips because i don't want you
guys having to watch a 65 minute clip
so there's 30 minute clip seats ready go
this is the story
after i got kicked out all right if you
watch the full podcast
it's the same [ __ ] story here we go
that way we have two thumbnails marty
all right
75 minute clip um it was a long that was
a long clip i didn't realize
i've been talking for 25 minutes so here
we go after i get kicked out
all right it's the morning after and i'm
at joe as i wake up
i wonder what kind of [ __ ] i'm in i just
she kicked me out
so i was like no what's what's going on
i don't think i ever told my mom this so
mom you're about to hear this
you know what [ __ ] you're lucky you're
lucky this is all that happened all i'm
gonna do is talk about the facts
anyway uh my dad calls me from oregon my
dad's already moved to oregon at this
point
and he's like your mom told me what
happened i'm like yeah she told you she
punched me in the face
what yeah she punched me in the face and
didn't do [ __ ] i thought you guys used
to fight
i i kind of like didn't call him i was
like how you were getting knocked
unconscious
what's wrong with you dad you had a weak
ass chin
and then but my dad doesn't have a weak
chin so it's like my mom must have been
a beast when she was 17
knocking [ __ ] on asleep and uh
oh god here you go um my dad tells me
yeah okay so i'm gonna talk to your mom
i know she's real mad
two days go by i'm at joe's i don't even
go to school because i know
they're gonna pick me up at school and
i'm gonna get in trouble i just didn't
want to know where i was at
two days later my dad calls me and says
hey i'm on my way down there i'm like
for what the [ __ ]
for what man and he goes yeah i'm gonna
pick you up go
yeah you're gonna pick me up like me and
like you're not gonna pick me up what
are you talking about you're driving
from oregon
because me and my mom are fighting he
goes no no uh i'm gonna take custody to
you
and i just started busting up like yeah
[ __ ] right
now right when i have all my friends and
i got a good clientele of people i'm
selling we
do [ __ ] yeah right and uh he
goes yeah yeah um
you're gonna we're gonna come to oregon
and go dad you should stop driving right
now
you're not i'm not getting in your truck
you're gonna have to drag me into your
truck i'm never
[ __ ] moving with you and i i said
[ __ ] moving with you
he goes thomas i don't know what you
think is gonna happen
but i'm gonna get you into that truck
and you're coming to portland with me
and i go dad
i don't know what you think is gonna
happen i know you're stuck i know my
dad's stubborn
he doesn't understand the level the
level of if i'm not doing it i'm not
doing it that i have in my heart
i will [ __ ] fight you first and i did
so
this is what happened guys this is uh
getting kicked out
of my house my mom is such a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right she knew the only thing i cared
about was like my homies at the time
my mom went to the courthouse and signed
all her parental rights over
the next day signed him right over to my
dad without even
[ __ ] telling me knowing that i had to
move to portland marty
this is what she did to me she did it on
purpose
the night that my dad said that i went
to sneak back to my mom's house and see
if i can have a key i was in stick in
the back door and get some of my [ __ ]
because i was i was about to not live at
my grandma's i'm not living in my dad's
not living in my mom's
you guys better find me like i was only
going on the run so i got all the [ __ ]
that i really wanted
like i got some of my packers [ __ ] that
i knew she was gonna throw away i put in
my backpack
it's little things and i went there at
night
it was night time and i jumped the fence
like i always [ __ ] did i jumped the
fence
and the trash can's right there and as
i'm getting off the fence i could see my
mom
in the living room through the blinds
that are like barely open right
they're barely open not enough like
where she can there's no light really
right behind me so i'm not backless you
just see a shadow of a dude creeping
i know my house like there's no light
like if someone's out there it'd always
creep me out because i wouldn't be able
to see them unless i shine my light
you know what i'm saying like there's no
street light right behind the the window
in the kitchen or in the living room
so i look in i call my mom
on my cell phone i go she answered i go
mom
what's going on dad said that he's
coming to get me yeah so um i'm signing
you right so she starts going in on me
like yeah
so you're gonna have to move to oregon
you're gonna do all that and yeah you're
no longer my uh
under my right so yeah [ __ ] off
basically i go mom why would you do that
to me what's wrong with you i love the
grandma dolores
you did but she knew if i lived in grand
dolores i would be happy and she was
like no
no i can't knock your ass out i'ma
[ __ ] make you move
that's what her plan was like all right
it's like a sore loser thing you
couldn't knock me
i should just pretend to be asleep and
just stay at my mom
oh you got me or anyway
um she says that i'm on the phone with
her
on the phone with her she has no idea
guys that i can see her
she had no idea i'm looking at her
here's the door i'm back here on the
window on the other side of the room i
can see
i could see her she's right here's the
door here's the couch couch comes out
like this the tv's up here so she's
almost looking at me but like looking
this way
so the her attentions are at the tv and
i'm right there
right so it's bright you're not you
can't see i know that house you can't
really see out that window
so i knew if i'm standing there she's
not gonna see me so i'm just sitting
there on top of the trash can at this
time i got off the fence when i spotted
her
i hopped on the trash can and i'm
[ __ ] just looking at her like oh
hey and that's why i said that [ __ ] i
just want to see her reaction when i
talk to her she's like
i can see her face like yep i'm like oh
you you love this
[ __ ] you and uh i call my grandma
dolores and i tell her she goes i know
i know she told me and she's just like
all sad like
your dad's on his way here he's gonna
i'm like i know he's on his way here
she's like i know you're not gonna go
with it my grandma you know me
i am not getting in that car [ __ ] no i
didn't say [ __ ] i would never cuss my
grandma
and uh you guys ready
my grandma grace calls my i call my
grandma grace i call my grand grace let
her know what's going on she's like i
know your dad told me
i'm like grandma he just got off drugs
he moved to oregon to be get clean and
now i got to move with his ass
and she's like i know i know but it's
your dad
you have to listen to him he has all the
rights that's all i remember she has all
the rights and i'm like oh this [ __ ]
won she won you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then i called my grandma hang up and
my grandma says i'm gonna call your mom
and i'm gonna talk to her
my grandma calls this is why i'm
bringing this up my grandma calls my mom
and i know it's her
because i can see her and i know my
grandma says she's just gonna call
my mom i can hear my mom i can hear her
talking
my mom started fake sobbing oh
he looked like he was gonna hit me he
looked just like elmer when he used to
beat me
and like i got he just got to learn
before he turns into a woman peter
and she's fake sobbing
and i don't um i don't know if you ever
knew this i was watching your ass
with the tv switching colors i could see
like the glare moving on her
and i'm just looking at her i'm like
this like
oh my god no [ __ ] way you punched me
in the face
you hit me that's all i kept thinking
and she
was like yeah so he's on his way down
here we're gonna we're gonna talk about
moving thomas out of here because i
don't want him to turn into one of these
one of these men my grandma used to get
beat up too by my grandpa when they were
younger
so she's like trying to relate like you
know how how they are and she's like
and then she's like i i just don't know
what to do and she go okay
call me back hangs up instantly right
back to normal no sobbing no more fake
crying no more nothing and i just went
whoa i've never seen that side of you
before holy
[ __ ] and that's when i went i think i
hate you
i think i don't like you at all anymore
and that's when i started to dislike my
mom
so you guys remember i told you like
there's a long time to talk to my mom i
told my mom for a long time
not because of this it's some other [ __ ]
couple years later but this is
this is what led to it i remember
looking at her and just like
oh [ __ ] you're psychotic huh
you're gonna do whatever the [ __ ] it
takes so i didn't get my stuff because i
knew she was sitting right there i only
went over there to see because i
she parked in the garage i went over
there to see if she wasn't home so i can
get my [ __ ] and leave
i see that ordeal i go back to joe's i
tell him he goes [ __ ] i'm like bro
i just saw her turn on fake sobbing i'm
done
she's going to do whatever she wants
like she's going to do whatever she can
to get the [ __ ] out of here because she
knows
that she's pissed uh i know it's a long
story sorry but here we go
this is what starts it my dad calls me
hey i'm a merced come meet me to graham
as i go dad i know you drove this far
but i did tell you to turn around
so you wasted your time i told like i'm
sorry you wasted your time
but i'm not getting in your car i'm not
moving with you rights or not
i will leave and i started saying can i
get emancipated
you have to have one parent signature
you know my dad ain't signing it my mom
definitely ain't signing it
um i was like let me get emancipated
i'll get a [ __ ] job i'll get an
apartment i was just like
please dad i told my dad like that you
just got [ __ ] clean
you've never been my dad you've never
been there for me now you want to be
there for me when i don't want you to be
this is the time i want to be with my
friends i'm going to school and he goes
thomas you're becoming a liar
i was becoming a liar i don't want you
to be the same person i turned into
because i would used to be really really
really good person to do drugs
i don't want to see you do the same
thing that i did you're becoming a liar
and
i'm like dad i'm not becoming a liar and
in my head i'm like damn i was just
lying to smell some [ __ ] [ __ ] is he
right
i was thinking like [ __ ] is he right but
um and i told my dad this is the time i
don't want you to be a dad
out of all the years i've been alive
you've never been there except for now
and i don't want you to be
i told you dad i'm not going and i told
him like try to be nice about like that
i'm not gonna go i'm sorry
i can't i'm not gonna go just not gonna
happen and he laughed he goes i don't
think you know but this is not a choice
and he talked to me like i talked to him
like yeah we're related
like he i could see him like that this
is not a choice
my dad looks just like me so i can see
what his face is
and [ __ ] my dad was almost my age
when this happened [ __ ]
um i'm a little younger but still um
i tell my dad you're gonna have to
tackle me
and put me in a car and hold me down
when you pump gas
because the second you stop i'm popping
out the car you're gonna have to chase
me down and you know i'm faster than you
and i told him like you know i'm faster
than you're gonna have to chase me down
you have to call the cops you're gonna
have to get people to
hold me down to put me in the car anyone
what dad did
he call the cops my dad got there and i
told him
dad i'm not coming goes thomas by the
morning if you're not at grandma's
there's going to be a warrant out for
you and i told him like dad
are you ser and i me and him are super
cool so i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me right now i was very
like hurt by it like are you [ __ ]
serious
and i was at anthony's house and i was
in there and i remember i looked at
anthony
and i told him everything he goes [ __ ]
and that's when i knew that it was over
no matter what i was gonna have a
warrant
i got a warrant [ __ ] that i ain't going
back two days i was on the [ __ ] run
hell nah i was literally on the run i
would sprint to wherever i was going
remember i told you i used the stealth
mode i used to run to bush to bush
when i saw cars coming because i didn't
want it to be a [ __ ] undercover like
the uh
caprices you just see some kid at night
you look young under curfew or run his
name you have a warrant out for your rat
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] um it wasn't a warrant it was more
like a
underage i don't know what he called it
he said something and i go dad you don't
even know what the [ __ ] that word mean
don't be throwing that [ __ ] at me i
remember he said that [ __ ]
and i called him the next day go dad you
should just leave man i'm not gonna do
it can i get emancipated and that's what
i should kept asking kept asking
and um he just started getting more
upset
so i finally made it all the way to
sixth street if you guys know where i'm
at i'm all the way
past walmart way past walmart where the
new development is and i get all the way
to sixth street um
i get to sixth street to my grandma
dolores is i'm like looking around i go
around the back jump the back fence go
through the back door
my grandma oh grandma oh my god okay i'm
like here dad was just here my grandma i
love my grandma dolores
she was looking out for me your dad was
just here i go grandma is this real i
told her is this
real because your mom is mad and you
know we can't do anything about it
because you know i don't have any rights
over you and my grandma's looking at me
like you're
you have to go and i look at my ground
like grandma
i don't want to go and she got she
started tearing up and i'm like
are you i have to leave now all my
friends are here
i have to just go to a new school now in
another state while i'm [ __ ] nobody
knows but i'm selling
[ __ ] come on you're gonna [ __ ]
up everything i just did
and it took me a long time
those [ __ ] gonna have new
dealers when i get back so
i'm like grandma [ __ ]
and then my dad pulls up right he he
must have been watching me on the other
side of the street
or something i don't know what happened
he pulled up two minutes to meet my
grandma talking
boom walked in the door i looked back
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] i look at my dad and it's all cool
still and i'm looking i'm pleading with
my grandma's like
asking like can you just stay here uh
you just get the rights to me like my
grandma's trying
and i'm like dad are you [ __ ] and i'm
just saying it
over and over like are you [ __ ]
kidding me and then
he's looking at me pissed at this pose
like you get in my truck i go dad i'm
not getting in your truck you're gonna
have to drag me in there
he goes all right hold on he goes
outside and he walks back in with two
cops
there's two cops outside waiting for me
because i ran
come on man come on big tall ass white
dude which i saw
like when i was at the gym eight years
later and he was working out next to me
i go
[ __ ] [ __ ] not your fault he walks
me outside he's like
this exact thing happened to me when i
was young man i had to move my dad my
mom signed the right things like this
exact thing
[ __ ] you train probably came from merced
probably been driving around since this
day
and i [ __ ] he's like i do this exact
same thing
and uh you just have to do it he's like
no matter what i did there's no way
around it you have to go
he has the rights you have no rights
until you're 18. he's all tough it out
to your 18 man
but you have to get in that car oh and
you have to get in the truck my dad's
pick up
and i look at the cop i'm like all right
man
so i go can i go to the bathroom
and my dad goes stand in the backyard
there's a window in the back in the
bathroom like
[ __ ] i was about to jump out that back
window and i was gonna be gone
he knew me too well man he knew me too
well
i was like dude that little window [ __ ]
and i even stood
on top of the bathtub to peek and their
cop was
right there i'm like [ __ ] there's
nothing i can do right when i open the
door the cop was right outside
right outside the [ __ ] bathroom door
i was like i'm in prison
so the cops leave i tell my dad i'm like
alright dad
all right we'll move can i get my stuff
the cops drive away my dad's talking me
for like five minutes
five minutes later i just i booked it
i ran away i started running right where
you pulled up earlier i ran in between
those two planners
i went between those two players and
started hooking it left toward the tree
because my dad's not faster than me
that i thought my dad caught me
so [ __ ] fast i can hear pop
pop heavy ass [ __ ] work boots and i'm
like no
no i can hear him i can hear him and i
went all right all right all right
all right i stopped and he bear hug me
like from like he's behind me bear hug
me
and i was like [ __ ] man
i was like [ __ ] you and i started i was
mad at him like [ __ ] you dude this is
some [ __ ]
and i started going in like you never
[ __ ] been there ever
always on drugs never want to be around
but now you want to i was just
letting them have it cause i was pissed
and then he goes i don't give a [ __ ]
what you say he squeezed me hard he's
like you're coming to [ __ ] organ with
me
and then i turned around
i'mma flex and bust out of here like in
my noble express that's what i tried to
do
but i turned around and he like loosened
up i turned around and i was talking
to him like this face to face i'm like
come on dad
[ __ ] and i'm talking to him and then
then he's like you think you're strong
man but you're not getting out of this
and i'm like dad
i'm so much stronger than you and i went
nothing i went ah i tried to bust out i
was benching like 260 at the time
no no 270 at that time when i got to
port i was doing like three plus but
i was i was pretty i was pretty strong
for a kid
and i remember like whoa
[Music]
this was strong there ain't no [ __ ]
way i'm getting out of here
and the cop i guess he had like told him
to stay around
but the [ __ ] were still there a
couple blocks away and they were like
circling the blocks
my dad had a feeling he knew better
maybe he did this when he was younger i
don't know but
my dad is there and i'm trying to get
out as hard as i can guys
as hard as i possibly can i'm trying to
wiggle out of this [ __ ] death grip
and let me like this [ __ ] upset
i've been talking forever sorry
and he's just talking [ __ ] to me like
you're not getting out of this i'm
stronger than you and i kept going no
you're not and i would try to get out
because i knew i was strong i tried to
like do the old body weight
and dip out from under it nothing would
work he had me he
was not letting my ass go he finally
caught me
so remember this is two days of him
trying to find me two days at him
driving around town going to friends
houses
trying to find me
all right so here we go
the cop rolls around by the armory and
it's coming toward us but like he's not
looking at it they're not coming toward
us
we're here street goes next to us and
takes a left he's on the far end of the
army he could see us
if he just takes the left and looks but
if he takes a left he's going to see us
in about 20 seconds
my dad sees him and just goes hi
and puts his arm up in waves in the
second he is like the
uh the second he released a little i
slipped out that [ __ ] started running i
started running down the street and by
and i had
a couple sec i had like the movement on
him so i burned him
i was burning him because he wasn't
trying to catch up to me he was like
running behind me and pointing at me
yelling at the cops and i could see his
light go on i went [ __ ]
my homie well my husband homie ramon
lives at the end of the block and i know
there's like a little duplex next door
and nobody lives there but in the back
ramone's backyard
i can get there into the backyard i can
get to the backyard of that duplex
so the cop is coming around i have at
least
a six second lead on these [ __ ]
right cop even if you wanted to burn out
and smash go 80 he's still got to take a
complete
90 degree angle turn he's not gonna
slide around the corner to catch a
teenager
you know what i'm saying so i'm like all
right cool i can hear my dad there he is
there he is he just turned i can hear my
dad yelling
and the whole time like you're a little
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and because you're faster than me and
you're stronger [ __ ] you
and i took the left i took the right and
they thought like they were going to
catch me right there
i took a right and i just jumped over
the fence i don't care what was behind
it or if someone lived there i just
jumped over the nearest fence
like uh high jumped it like in the
olympics
hip on the top and i flip myself over
you know i'm talking about like uh
you jump you get your hips as high as
you can you hit that fence top and flip
i just landed and laid flat and then
three or four seconds later can hear my
dad where'd he go and i heard the cop
we're gonna find him don't worry
whoop put his light his uh his little
siren not like the
full siren but he did that little you
know i'm talking about marty
and i can hear him like and i can hear
my dad
[ __ ] like he was pissed and i
could hear the work
and i can hear him i can hear him hear
the sirens i'm laying flat
laying [ __ ] vampire style just
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like friday
when they're in the pickup truck
yes exactly what i'm doing but in weeds
right i'm sitting there i'm like [ __ ]
okay three minutes goes by i can hear my
dad you better come on now
i can hear my dad like i'm a [ __ ]
fugitive and i can look through the
fence crack
and i can see my dad and i could see i
remember what he was wearing and
everything i could see him go like that
stop and talk to the cop and the cop
took off my dad started walking back
toward my grandma's
and i knew like okay they're gonna go to
another spot they think they lost me for
now
i lay there for [ __ ] 30 minutes i
don't give a [ __ ] with my dad
i don't give a [ __ ] he's a ninja
apparently because he caught me twice
that day
or he bear hugged me i thought i was
gonna get out nope
and then uh that's what happened right
there
30 minutes later i started just trekking
back
to joe's but this is where the warriors
comes out
i have to look out for cops i have to
look up for my dad i have to look out
for
uh anybody he might be having to look
for me my dad's got a white pickup at
the time and it's very distinct to pick
up
right so i'm just looking for the grill
all i'm looking for is the grill
and the headlights uh coming at me in
the streets right
so i had to run through the [ __ ]
ghetto right like warrior [ __ ] i had to
run through the ghetto
to the outskirts of town because joe
lives by the country but i have to go
down the one
single highway that's like a mile and a
half long so i have to
book it and book it so my decision was
i'm gonna run straight to my uncle
john's the one from the story times
i'm gonna run straight to my uncle john
and pepper's house tell him what's going
on
i get to the chevron gas station about a
mile for my grandma's and i see my dad's
truck on my no
[ __ ] way and it comes by me and it's
not my dad
same [ __ ] truck guys and i was just
like oh my god
and i started just sprinting all the way
to my uncle john's right
back past roller land we were just
talking about roller land i passed
roller land
uh 24th street like 11 14 or something
24th street
west 24th street i get there and my
uncle john's
right by his patio we're doing all the
coke from all story times right by his
patio
i knock on the door he comes out like
thomas
go john my dad's like i know your dad
was just here he's like
where hasn't he been where is he i feel
like [ __ ] uh
was a candy man's after me dude
everywhere i can think of he's already
there
and then i talked to uncle john like
dude he's chasing me
he's like i know he said you just ran
away from the cop like john
what the [ __ ] do i do cuz thomas you
know you can't stay here because he's
gonna come back
and he knows i'm way faster than uncle
john used to be fast for having a
guy with a big gut that [ __ ] can
run so [ __ ] violently fast
and in flip-flops all right in flip fuzz
so
he goes thomas you know that's a lie if
i say i saw you
and you ran away from me because you
know i can catch you
yeah he goes so this is what's going to
happen i'mma say you jumped away into
the creek
okay that's that's tight that's cool he
goes
if he sees me because he might be
watching me right now that's what he
says if he might be watching us right
now because
we're right by the track the railroad
tracks say some jeepers creeper [ __ ]
i feel him that's how it was for my dad
like yo my dad turned into a [ __ ]
vigilante the second he got those papers
signed to his ass
after being a big dad the yeah he wasn't
a deadbeat dad he just
he wasn't he was on drugs and he wasn't
there when he was supposed to be i'd be
waiting like
nine ten hours on his friday to pick us
up he'd be like pick us up at two
i'm sitting there by the door until
[ __ ] 11 30 at night and like oh he's
coming tomorrow
and then it wouldn't show up and then be
like next weekend like
i waited by the door for a weekend
waiting for your ass i did that for five
years
so that's what i mean by you weren't
even there [ __ ]
so i told my uncle john what happened
because i know he told me
and he goes here uncle john goes and the
[ __ ] camel non-filters you guys know
that soft pack he goes bam
he's like 10 secrets he goes you take
these and he gives me a little bit like
pinch of weed he had he goes here
you got to go because he's coming back i
know he's coming back and i go john
thank you thank you and he gave me a
lighter too because i never lighter
because i left my backpack i didn't know
my dad was going to bust into my
grandma's
i was having a conversation with my bag
on the ground and she came with cops
so when i went outside to run i didn't
have my backpack yet so i was [ __ ] i
had nothing my packers [ __ ]
ever all my extra clothes was in that
backpack
i'm hoofing it right so he goes here you
go man i'm like john thank you
and i started walking down the railroad
tracks guys and uh
he only said you're gonna jump in the
river if your dad comes though
because he know i can catch you and he's
gonna know i helped you
all right i'll take that and i walk to
the cigs i start
power smoking cigarettes i usually smoke
hell of cigarettes
and i go to joe's i let him know what's
going on i call my dad one more time
like dad
he goes where the [ __ ] are you that's
what he said
like i have been looking for you like i
could tell he was
mad and i go dad you're not gonna catch
me
it's just not gonna happen you had me
and you're still not gonna catch me dad
you had the cops with you
and you're not gonna get me i told he's
like thomas you're never going to be
able to go to school
you can't get your license you are going
to have a warrant you are on the run
you are under you are you he said you
belong to me
basically and i go dad come on man
because i knew i was [ __ ] like
come on like i was trying to plead like
give me emancipate like i was just over
over and over and over and that night i
went to bed like [ __ ] i know it's over
next morning i just walked to my grandma
grace's my dad was already there just
walked to my grandma's
he was already there his truck was
packed didn't say a word i just
sat in the passenger seat just like that
right the passenger scene like that's it
he saw me didn't say anything
just got in the car started it we drove
to my mom's house so i could pick up the
rest of my clothes and [ __ ]
i let my mom have it she was there and
goes hey
yeah by the way yeah fake sobbing yeah
real good
she goes what and i'd left it like yeah
i [ __ ] saw you
and that's all i said she went huh so
yeah mom that's what i meant by that
that day
and she didn't know i knew so i went and
got my stuff and i walked by here like
i was mad i always act like my mom was
not like an enemy and she was pissed
i shouldn't act like that she shouldn't
act like that anyway
i look at her like if it was the anime i
would have flicked my seek
that's how i felt like [ __ ] you and
i got in the car didn't say one single
word to my dad the entire trip didn't
eat
didn't acknowledge didn't do anything i
was just staring straight like
trying not to grind my teeth because i
was so [ __ ] mad
i didn't eat the whole way he's like
thomas you have to [ __ ] eat something
man it's been like 10 hours like i
didn't say anything
you don't have to talk to me you don't
have to talk to me but you live with me
now and i just staring straight and
just like you [ __ ] i don't want
to move
like i was mad and then um
we got almost to portland and he went to
go get gas and i went
oh my god thank god because he every
time he was just getting gas and pumping
it right there and i just wanted to
i wanted him to know that i was [ __ ]
mad like don't talk to me
but this time the card didn't work right
when we got to oregon the card reader
didn't work she had to go inside i went
thank god
i started eating [ __ ] i'm like i'm so
[ __ ] hungry i'm so [ __ ] hungry
so i started eating [ __ ] i was scarfing
it down because i didn't want him to
know that i was hung i wanted to know i
was
you know i was being petty as [ __ ] i
remember i was eating
[ __ ] and he started coming back i just
stopped and he got in he goes where's my
sandwich at
and say [ __ ] he looked at me and i go
[ __ ] i didn't realize i hate your
sandwich
so he knew automatically that i ate i
didn't want him i wanted to be like he
didn't eat
he didn't drink water he didn't go to
the bat he didn't talk to me
[ __ ] his man i just wanted him to get
the vibe like yes send me back fool
cause i didn't talk to my dad for a week
after i moved there and talked to my dad
for a [ __ ] i was so
heated and then i came to more of the
realization like
okay you've never had a son basically
before i get it now like you want you're
clean you wanna
you want to help i get it but [ __ ] off
don't be taking me away from my friends
like that
and that guy's is it getting kicked out
moving to oregon story
it's quite long goddamn it's quite long
how long did it last i stayed there for
like seven eight months
and then i moved back there right when i
turned uh right when i graduated high
school i moved back to oregon
because i realized like yo organ's a
[ __ ] i can make money out here there's
no sales tax i smoke weed
and um that only lasted for like
eight months again a year maybe at that
i don't like oregon anymore
dude i completely forgot we're doing a
podcast i was just talking and i was
about to say yeah i'm [ __ ] tired man
oh my god i'm burned i have dreams like
that that was like
that reminded me i'm realizing i have
high intense suspense action-packed
dreams like this
i should suck that [ __ ] was just a
[ __ ] regular day
yeah that's the same house that made my
uncle john smoke crack at
but it's not i'm not on purpose not on
purpose we accidentally smoke crack and
i know you're like you know
you actually smoke crack because we're
trying to smoke coke
it turned out to be crazy fine line it
was dark
i was just crushing up a rock you know
cocaine has rocks too right
oh man um so yeah we're two hours in
talking about some
talking about life drugs problems
accomplishments
these were definitely problems in drugs
so uh
yeah guys i moved that does me get
kicked out and then uh
i moved back with my mom she's like all
right you can come back home
like nine ten months later when my
grades were top-notch i'm not
dis in oregon while dissing organ your
education system is [ __ ] stupid
you're letting kids get away with murder
the most advanced thing was chemistry
that's the most advanced [ __ ] class
you could take at that high school
that's a requirement down here
you don't have to even pass your classes
marty if you one
essay a year per grade if it
meets the requirements of the state you
pass that grade whether you have fs or
not oh
are you [ __ ] kidding me so all i had
was electives when i moved to oregon
because
i knew i was moving back to california
someday before i graduate i go i'm not
taking your requirements i'm just going
to take the electives so i had art and
weightlifting
that's all i had art weightlifting for
the second half i was there but then i
had
regular school before but it was sick
oregon's awesome
they treat everybody like they're dumb
it's easy to pass school
i'm with it dude what the [ __ ] were you
the long-ass talk
man that was an intense story i'm sorry
for everybody driving out there going
damn this [ __ ] won't get on stay
on topic i know
and that's my bad well there really is
no topic
i'm just getting kicked out yeah that
was an intense story that was my dad
uh yeah oh man
uncles say he ran into the creek my
uncle was so
down he was so down for that one dude
um okay i think that's about it man do
you have
do you have anything you want to get
we're over two hours and i was like yo
let's just do an hour today
because you know we got to do stuff it's
two hours in [ __ ]
um i think that was it it's those bomb
rips that got me high and started making
me ranty
rant oh gee i gotta make that strain
dude rant oh gee
why because you'll never stop talking i
love it
yeah i need to stop smoking so much
syndica on this show
you can hear me like yeah just [ __ ]
like just like yeah bro
i just turned a polly short um
yeah i think that's everything man we
we're just busy
we're just [ __ ] busy i'm about to go
home and edit right now yeah we're about
to it's about to be
edit city it already has been deep
[ __ ] edit city but
marty went three days strong and that
just made peluso uh
episode and youtube decided to [ __ ] us
and take 14
hours to upload so you rushed for
nothing i was you know i was rushing for
like five
days straight because i was going into
that paw patrol there was a lot of
overload it was already rushing
and then just it was like sometimes when
you do this you battle technical things
sometimes things just go wrong
but sometimes it's just a lot and
everything goes right
but it's still just a lot yep
a lot of overlays in the last episode it
was awesome yeah yeah um
yeah i think that's i think that's about
it we uh today talked about racism
i'm already killing [ __ ] innocent ass
butterflies
on purpose no butterfly look at me
stupid again oh
you know what i saw him i saw him look
at you wrong
yo marty you marty sent me the best
picture ever
the other day he sent me a picture of
him for his first mixtape cover the
behind the scenes
wait no that was the picture you kept
huh that was the actual picture
yeah yeah it was real good
i love seeing him going marty you were
just
the kid because you were never out there
yeah you were a kid back then that [ __ ]
was funny
yeah we're gonna have to make a little
montage right there just to let kids
know it can happen
there's a [ __ ] picture marty marty
sends me random pictures no context
cause of him when he was younger he sent
me a picture like a couple weeks ago
it's like it's him i mean i talked about
this it's him
hella just talty with like
nine dudes he's the only white dude in
the whole [ __ ] picture
everyone looks hood as [ __ ]
all their shirts are past their knees
and they all have matching shirts and it
says
what you eat don't make me [ __ ] and
marty's standing there on the side
oh did you design that shirt
i mean it was just text but yeah you did
it huh yeah you were always the guy
yeah that was my boy's idea but yeah oh
dude but yeah that's barney man i love
swimming
we got pulled over and that whole story
that i told earlier it was picking up
those tees
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah we got him
from the flea market
no back that is [ __ ] comedy bro
that's even better yeah pulled over to
make these shirts man we gotta
he got his ass touched we're like now we
just went to the flea market we're just
getting t-shirts we just
and they still searched you yeah but i
think that's why they let us go though
because it was like a legit excuse
i mean but still this is also illegal
yeah um
but yeah that's marty's uh i can't yo
you should frame those and put them
around your house so your kids go
know where you came from [ __ ]
this is buffalo
no they don't do you yeah i kind of yeah
i can only imagine when mario's at home
his [ __ ] around this block
y'all stalked him for two days
[ __ ]
marty just turned into a different
person when he came out here
when i go home with my kids yeah i'm
gonna get some hard [ __ ] with
the blowtorch to come over here on his
ass
a pair of pliers and a blow torch damn
that was a [ __ ] up scene paul fishing
yeah so um we still try to end it and
didn't even end it all right
guys thank you so much for hanging out
with us this doesn't even feel like
we're ending the podcast i feel like we
just
can keep going forever but it's
i think we should wrap this one up i
don't want to give up any more so yeah i
don't want to give away too much man
because there's so much more that
happened
after that story when i moved to oregon
technically podcasts are like an hour
and some change so we just try to over
deliver yeah we're just trying to have
fun all right we want you guys to not be
bored
so uh i'll give you the rest of what
happened when i moved to pleasantville
uh in oregon basically and i was the
only brown kid
and then i found other brown kids and
then they shunned me because i was a
not a spanish speaker i'll just leave it
at that i'll tell you guys the rest of
what happened
i got shunned all right so guys thank
you so much for watching this is uh this
has been fun go check out pushtrees.com
all right i forget to say that go check
out pushtrays.com
we can say whatever we want huh wait no
it's youtube still so we might get in
trouble
go check out pushers.com we got a lot of
shirts
stuff you may or may not be able to
smoke out of a couple of hats couple
hats as
trays oh yeah sorry pencil trays
[ __ ] youtube always censoring
[ __ ] man
so guys go check out pushtrees.com but
most of all
dopaziola.com check it out it's the home
of the podcast for push to every single
thing you can shop there you can do
whatever you want
sign up to be a member get newsletters
get early release do
everything that you want to do with the
podcast with dopaziola stuff with
pushtrees
go to dobasil.com also dope as
usualpodcast.com you can click that if
you want
right marty but it goes just redirects
right to our section in dopaziola.com
so either way it's just redirects but if
you don't remember go straight to dope
as usual.com
yeah i think that's everything man we
got some we have some good [ __ ] coming
oh yeah all of our uh
let's just leave it at that we have a
lot of [ __ ] dropping we got some new
stuff coming
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you for supporting if you can
remember to do that hit the like button
for those of you in the chat
appreciate you guys for hanging out in
the chat this long been over two hours
you guys are still here
thank you so much um yeah i think i'm
gonna end it for everyone driving please
be safe
have a good day april's coming it's the
first 4 20
after the shittiest everybody waited 20
years to do for
2020 and it was quarantined so this is
this is our for 2020 this year all right
we'll think of something fun to do but
thank you guys so much for watching
marty from jurassic graphics thank you
so much for being here thank you guys so
much for hanging out with us
i am dopa ziola until next time have a
dope ass day
my leg hurts i got high and forgot to
like reposition my leg and when i moved
it right now
it did that whole stick thing yeah it's
all [ __ ] dead
remember that one time forgot to move my
[Music]
extremities
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]